the white house had a party a
celebration for the inflation reduction
act on a day when we are facing a near
record collapse in the market and even
cardi b
respect cardi
came out ranting about or outraged about
inflation costs the rising costs of rent
wondering how are people surviving this
and i got respect for cardi b for doing
it because she supported biden and the
democrats in 2020 and now she's just
like i don't care like this is messed up
but at the same time
joe biden's out there on the white house
celebrating ha things are great
meanwhile people in this country are
suffering you know
maybe the real reason they're
celebrating is that
they're zealots
they've got people who blindly follow
and just believe all this stuff and
they're going to vote for them either
way
so it's an it's the unfortunate reality
of where we're at but uh that's what's
happening well i will say one good new
one thing that's good news is the emmys
happened and you probably didn't notice
because i didn't and the ratings were
the lowest uh record lows like five
million people watched it's no longer a
cultural event we're moving past this
and it's good news i think we're gonna
win the culture war and uh that's one of
the reasons why so we'll get into that
and more but before we get started my
friends head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com
and pick up virtual shield download it
today it's a virtual private network
service it provides you a basic layer of
security as you browse the web so that
prying eyes government hackers
government actors just general bad
people it makes it a lot harder for them
to steal your information again surfing
internetsafe.com
and virtual shields vpn service is
compatible with all devices it allows
you to browse the web safely securely
and anonymously using their global
network of servers and private ips it'll
let
okay big big name isps and other third
parties will not be able to monitor and
sell your internet history when using
their vpn service your traffic is run
through their secured encrypted servers
that means any restrictions censorship
blocks on your internet are bypassed you
get fast reliable always secure service
completely free for 30 days it's
available on mac windows iphone ipad
android or chrome virtual shield does
all the work all i got to do is download
it click go and you're good to go and it
also will route your uh your wi-fi it'll
completely encrypt your wi-fi connection
blocking hackers and everyone else from
accessing any accessing any of your data
so again head over to
surfinginternetsafe.com shout out to
virtual shield they're our first sponsor
they've been here the entire time going
back years all the way back to when i
had just one little youtube channel with
like no subscribers on it so i'm really
proud to have them as a sponsor and i
appreciate their support
also head over to timcast.com become a
member and support our work directly we
have a members only show coming up at
about 11 p.m tonight we do that monday
through thursday as a member you're
supporting our journalists our newsroom
and our other shows and helping make all
of this possible joining us
to talk about all this and more is
patrick kurelcy how you doing it's great
to be here tim really appreciate it who
are you patrick corellichi uh co-host of
red pilled america i've been told it's
the best storytelling and storytelling
show in the country i wouldn't ever say
that but i've been told that i do it
with my wife adriana cortez we've been
doing it since november 2018. right on
yeah welcome to the show thanks for
coming thank you for having me i really
appreciate it tim we've got this person
of color here luke rutkowski damn right
uh
i was going to say not represent uh
appreciate this is hold on real quick
this is my solution to the little
mermaid thing if they want a a person of
color to play ariel and the little
mermaid just get a polish person because
according to the coalition of
communities of color they are people of
color but they're also white like luke
with blonde hair and blue eyes you
better recognize welcome back beautiful
and amazing human beings this is
lukewarm here we are change.org it's
good to be back i'll be with you guys in
the chat room during the show and uh the
shirt that i'm wearing right now depicts
our uniter and chief saying trust us
we're the good guys and uh you can get
the shirt on the best political
shirts.com because you do i'm here thank
you so much for having me ian you're
here luke no one's peeing welcome back
man finally i'm on stage with luke
rudkowski patrick so patrick were you
red pilled at some point i was i was it
was 2009 i think well i i think we've
all been red pilled a bunch of times
before we had the big red pill but i
think uh obama was the thing that red
pilled me it was this socialist poster
that went around if you guys remember
him being painted white with as the
joker
and
i remember seeing that around town i had
a house that was like walking distance
from the hollywood bowl and i was
stunned that this socialism poster was
all over the place really early in his
presidency and they started calling the
artist racist
and i was like how is that racism and
then from there on a couple months after
that there was this big moment on msnbc
one of the biggest fake news moments
that i that i had witnessed at that time
was they had a guy that was carrying a
rifle at a obama health care
rally where he was basically trying to
get everybody behind the universal
healthcare that he was pushing the
mandate and they have this camera on
this guy and you see him his shirt you
see this rifle hanging from his his uh
shoulder and they're saying oh this
racist movement is coming after obama is
coming after obama
a couple days later is when the
blogosphere got really hot and they
started sleuthing it and they found out
the guy was black that msnbc
purposefully cut out his skin color and
i i saw that happening i was i was
stunned that a huge network like msnbc
would attempt to do something like that
and i think that was kind of it for me i
just kind of i i flipped
right on yeah well hey let's i'll we'll
get deeper on the show i'm sure lydia i
want to toss it over to you thank you
ian i am also here luke's shirt is great
tonight i'm just excited to be back with
luke and ian i feel like the gang's all
here patrick's gonna be awesome i was
talking to him before the show it's
gonna be cool let's get going all right
we got the story from the national
review the american people won biden
celebrates inflation reduction act as
market plummets over august inflation
news so i don't know if they have photos
but you get all they have all these
people celebrating on the white house
law and they're like the inflation
reduction act we did it meanwhile
everybody else on the internet is like
oh take a look at that oh what is that
finn fin twit what is this all things
finance tweets this is not a
cryptocurrency it's the u.s stock market
oh man
and i don't even think that's the worst
that just shows like a hundred point
fall off the story from market watch is
the dow jones books near 1300 point drop
as stocks record worst day since june
2022 so bravo joe biden
he's celebrating as everything's burning
down around this reminds me of that
george bush um mission accomplished meme
where he's standing on the aircraft
carrier it's like day three after the
war on terror begins and of course it
went on for 20 years this is a good one
that luke posted oh yeah i saw that one
i couldn't resist reposting it but but
another thing we should really consider
here is that a stock market is not the
real kind of effect of economy the stock
market is artificially inflated with the
federal reserve printing money and
giving it to many of these wall street
companies so even with the bailouts that
were secretly given by the federal
reserve to wall street we are still
seeing extremely negative impacts and
what we're seeing on the streets of the
united states is way worse than what
we're seeing on wall street and these
numbers 8.3 percent i mean that's
nothing compared to what you see out
there in the real world what you see out
there in the grocery stores and what you
see out there with people and their
rents yeah ian brought something up
before the show because we often talk
about where all the workers at and then
ian was like they're homeless the
homeless population is exploding right
now at least from what i've been
learning about los angeles
you're from los angeles
it's massive out there i've been there
my whole life in the suburbs of los
angeles or in los angeles and i was just
telling you guys i was saying earlier
that we went to a play recently and we
got off the freeway first thing person
we see is a naked person standing on a
corner
you know her breasts and i was i was
stunned how bad the homeless problem had
gotten in los angeles and it's not and
it's more than just the weather florida
doesn't have the same issue i think it's
a lot of it has a lot to do with the
ideology a lot to do with uh rehab
centers you know uh
or excuse me using obamacare and
loopholes and obamacare to bring
patients out but it's just gotten to a
point where people just step over it now
they don't even think much about it and
it's it's a it's a sad state of being if
you go over to the va area over by ucla
and this is like one of the richest
enclaves of los angeles it's right there
in beverly hills and just tent after
tent just going down this street outside
the va
and los angeles uh the los angeles crowd
just doesn't care much about it they
just they look the other way even here i
was in town today we don't have a big
town where we live which town is a
couple the one out west virginia yeah in
west virginia in charlestown yeah and
and there's a homeless guy there yeah i
never seen a homeless guy there but he
had a sign saying i don't want your
money i want a job
um so so seeing stuff like that seeing
people impacted so horribly so
negatively and these people are
celebrating these people are giving
victory speeches these people are having
musicians come to the white house lawn
and and play music and and act like they
did something great for the people it's
just such a smack in the face for anyone
playing they live in a bubble it's i was
thinking this jackson mississippi water
crisis is like should be number one news
in the world or at least in the united
states right now like a city one of our
greatest cities or largest cities has no
drinking water they're on like a boil
your water alert right now and it could
very well still be toxic um maybe um the
economy the inflation is probably the
biggest story but this one that people
are just like have somewhat of a blind
eye towards the fact that a city is
struggling to have drinking water have
you seen the running water that they've
been opening up on that it's like comes
out black and brown you know to touch on
your mission accomplished uh comment i
think they they know they can do this
because they don't have control of the
uh
they have control i should say of the
narrative machine the biden in them know
that hollywood's not going to come at
them the media is not going to come at
them
this entire narrative machine is not
going to call them out the same way that
they did with mission impossible i
remember that time at mission impossible
and
bush got raped over the pulled over the
coals on that for that comment you're
not going to see this happen with biden
because they do not
have the same kind of pushback this is
why we see the democrats can be so much
more corrupt than the republicans
because
they they have checks and balances on
the republicans through the media
through hollywood through the
literary industry and what have you so i
think that's part of the reason why
conservatives need to really
and the right or anyone from the
anti-woke world needs to get into the
culture game and start creating these
institutions like what you're doing now
what you're doing with music i really i
applaud you guys for getting into this
culture game talking about culture all
the time and creating the content
because otherwise they're just going to
keep getting away with this kind of yeah
i think about waking up and looking at
twitter like what happened today as
opposed to waking up and making
something and and being like this is
what happened because i made it happen
like
getting up and looking around at like
what's going on is kind of like a
reactionary way to live and it's we're
really in a place where we need to
create what's happening this is
important too you do need to talk about
things the media aspect is very very
important but on top of that the next
layer is creating content creating these
cultural movements if you look at back
at movies like jerry maguire for example
i love this this movie okay everybody
saw it there's this moment where jerry
maguire
is drunk and he grabs his assistant and
he he re-kills knowing that what he did
was wrong and he says oh i'm clarence
thomas now oh my god i'm clarence thomas
now i'm clarence thomas now they put
those kinds of messages in all of their
content and all their movies and all
their tvs just scene by scene story by
story painting the other side in a
certain way
and and so i think that's why it's so
important for us to get in this game
because we need to be able to push back
on these people when they gaslight us on
things like this inflation this
inflation act shout out to tom
mcdonald's song riot
if you guys haven't listened to it
already check it out
download it on itunes and check it out
on spotify because tom's one of the
leaders in
anti-establishment he's independent he's
producing his own media his latest song
is basically about him just like saying
screw off to the the establishment and
so i dig it and i'm and i wanted to
shout him out because you're completely
right about winning a culture war you
need culture
100 it's what defines what it means to
be america american right hollywood has
been defining that for decades and
decades we've won wars politically and
this is the difference between i think
the right and the left the left thinks
about success in decades the right
thinks about success in election cycles
and we're always talking about two years
ahead two years ahead two years ahead
where the left is talking 10 20 30 years
ahead they are
soaking in the seeds that they planted
back in the 40s and 50s and 60s right
now we're at this culture that we're
seeing right now that infiltrate that
took over 2020 in the summer of riots
didn't just happen overnight they've
been pushing this message out there
through their music and through their
films and through their television shows
for years that the republicans are
racist that the that their rights are
homophobes that the rights are you know
womanizers and what have you they've
been doing that for decades but for what
reason right so some people think it's
like a bigger conspiracy you know
marxist infiltrated the country or
something like that or i wonder if it's
just a cult chasing itself into you know
a spiral it is 100 a cult we were in the
belly of the beast for about 10 years
our daughter went to this really
prestigious uh private school we were
around
studio heads hollywood studio heads big
actors jason bateman melissa mccartney
had a kid in our class
scott what's his name that said that's
on this new series anyways bunch a bunch
of celebrities and we noticed very early
on that it was a cult there that they
were
this very insulated group that and
there's this one moment where we caught
this guy you're not going to believe
this guys we caught this guy getting in
bed with other people's kids okay what
five six seven year old kids oh my gosh
the entire community of the school was
behind us on us we called him out we
said what are you doing this is
dangerous this is at the very least it's
unsafe um and uh you know he came at us
and said he's gonna sue us connected to
a billion dollar family we said we're
not backing down there's nothing that
you can say that's going to stop us from
from calling you out on this the entire
hollywood community was behind us in
this group in this school
and he was smart what he said was
they're republicans these guys are
republicans that are calling me out
overnight
this entire community turned on us wow
and that's the the perfect example of a
cult where there's certain kinds of
groups that just have to be
shunned from the group and that's
exactly what they did it was a
fascinating experience to watch did the
guy keep sleeping in a bed with kids no
he stopped he actually got it in writing
from him that he was going to stop um
doing what was upsetting us he wouldn't
admit to that but we
we laid it out in line items you did
this you did this with four or five
different kids i want to trust the
writing i would just
send them to jail well
when you when you're in these
communities that you can get away with
these kinds of things because they have
their billion dollar families
and they they i think i'm i'm convinced
after this experience that that kind of
thing happens more often there than
anywhere else but it also shows this
kind of sexualization of kids it's
coming out from these communities it's
coming out they are the big pushers
behind a lot of this kind of
sexualization of kids out of this
community we see it in their television
shows we see it in their writing they're
they they control the cultural blueprint
through their screenwriters you see that
uh what's her name jeanette mccurdy was
that the actress the young actress yeah
there's these like she wrote a book
about the weird abuse someone made a
video compilation from her show or just
disney shows in general and there's just
weird stuff where like they have little
girls feet and they're like rubbing
ketchup on it and stuff like just really
creepy stuff you see that stuff in
cartoons all the time i just saw a meme
right now for a shrek movie and they
were they literally had a meme where
there was a very sexual thing just but
for a split second you could see it
they're constantly embedding these kinds
of things within their content well
there's the old legends
about uh you know disney right the
lighting oh yeah the lion king he lays
down it says sex and then i think the
the official explanation was no no no no
it says sfx is that what it was or
something like that then there's like
the cover of the little mermaid then
there's aladdin saying what do you say
go
what does he say tell me about taking
off your clothes there's a bunch of
wieners everywhere
let's just be real with each other
that's what it is
is it isn't what like the great mouse
detective had something did it oh i
don't i didn't see that one i don't
think yeah i don't i could be wrong
because i i i i learned all this from
watching some like newgrounds.com video
back in the day but it was like under a
carriage was a small
like porn frame or something i don't
know if that's real but that's like
another part of the legend or whatever
they've been working this stuff we saw
it in 2012 before the kind of whole
transgender kind of
movement started taking off in america
we saw it being pushed at this school
pretty heavily and then of course you
see these major writers you know writing
these series writing these movies and
they're part of this whole scene
and so we've been see i think that it's
been been embedded within the culture
for a while we always wonder how do
these things happen they happen because
we've allowed the left and the woke to
monopolize all of these institutions
that define what it means to be american
so you know
i think that's one of those kinds of
things where we the only way to fight
back the only way to push back is to
create our own institutions and get our
own messages out there here's what we're
doing one of the things that we're
working on here is aside from music and
you know cass castle like all of the
projects we've been working on have been
apolitical but one of the things we're
doing is we're setting up a physical
space
which will probably be
you know
we want to do like a gaming space board
games but we want to do events called
saturday morning cartoons
where saturday mornings you bring your
kids there's like a buffet of like
catering pancakes sausage waffles hash
browns and then we have like little
arcade games but we play cartoons that
parents approve
so we can bring back that you know we
used to wake up watching saturday
morning watch the cartoons and the
cartoons weren't so bad
we want to bring that kind of thing back
and we want to create a place where
neighbors can meet each other and hang
out build community and
build a culture around you know where we
live it's gold rush right now i think as
far as um you know the right the way
that they see this all happening at
disney and netflix and what have you
they want other options they just don't
have the options out there for so many
years i would tell people do not you
know you know give money these people's
movies and their television shows don't
subscribe but then the the
the pandemic hits and now people are
stuck at home they have nothing to do
they have no other options they need
options we got to do jack's pizza shack
jax jack's pizza oh yeah we do so big
yeah jack
you know he talks about pizza at
nationalism yeah
we drove past an old pizza hut and it
was all falling apart it's kind of sad
we ended up going but uh maybe that's
what we should do we should set up you
know jack's family-friendly pizza
emporium or whatever and then we can do
community events because that's another
big aspect to community so obviously
we're doing the internet-based stuff
we want to build culture but you can
also build culture at the local level
too jack's been smart jack's it's been
great about that back to your point uh
the subuno subconscious propaganda does
work and that's why they put these
little messages in there there's a
reason advertisers spend hundreds of
billions of dollars trying to get their
messaging out there and truly what
happens with children especially when it
comes to disney and all these other mega
corporations and the images and the
messages and and really the propaganda
deep down when you really look at it
when you're able to take a step back
because when you watch entertainment you
usually go into your kind of reptilian
brain you don't think you don't really
you just kind of sit there and consume
it you're in this phase where you're
just
getting injected with entertainment it's
not entertainment a lot of it is
propaganda a lot of it is programming
that programs people to believe families
are bad to believes healthy
relationships are bad and as you said to
make children in this kind of state
where of course they're going to be
prevented from having healthy
relationships in the future uh but but
the culture is extremely important we
have to fight back i think memes are
also extremely important like the meme
that tim just showed just a couple of
moments ago but there's another meme
that i that i saw today to bring this
back to the conversation that we
originally had here and it was of a
deutsche dog in the 1920s saying i lost
my house i lost my job i lost my savings
i lost everything and then you have the
[ __ ] chad
deutsch dog in 2020 saying i never had
any of those things
when you're seeing messages like that
and memes like that it resonates with
people because like yeah i never had
savings oh yes i don't have a house yes
i don't have a real job i have i have
this gig economy created by klaus schwab
in the world economic forum that
literally just screwing me over and not
giving me any kind of benefits or
anything that could actually sustain
sustain me as a human being so memes i
think are super super important
luke came to me
before the show and he was talking about
he was being he was unhappy and i said
have you considered owning nothing
things are looking up on the simplistic
hippie ian level that can work actually
yeah
with minimalism i live in an rv so i
went into the whole minimalistic aspect
i you know it's still impossible to pack
that that whole thing but but
in in in in a bigger element yes but
what they mean from it is is essentially
human slavery which they're slowly
conditioning us to be okay with by
getting rid of our financial ability to
prosper or have any kind of legitimate
healthy lifestyle so when you're seeing
people getting screwed over i mean
these inflation numbers these are just
the official numbers they don't
represent what actually is happening out
there in the real world since uh last
year groceries went up 13.5 percent rent
went up 6.7
airline fares 13.4 percent electricity
15.8 percent that's a lot higher than
the 8.3 reported just in august what's
happening out there is a total bloodbath
the poorest people of the world are
being screwed over are literally just
being
just taken by their feet and shaken by
all these globalist biology leaders that
that just want everything from them and
it's disgusting and it's sad and it the
poverty the homelessness the the
suffering is created by politicians and
because we don't see what's going on
because we're divided because we're
conquered were were allowing this to
happen
somebody just super chatted a correction
they said it's disney's the rescuers it
has a frame with a woman in the window
full frontal snokes
um
you know just think about where we've
gotten to you know with everything luke
said
i'm i'm hearing you know all this
economic stuff and then i'm thinking
about what you said and imagining just
like all ages drag shows and i'm just
like
rome is burning man one hand
so i i kind of feel like you know what
you can do is scream
as you fall to the earth or or you can
enjoy you know you're skydiving learn to
fly
you know and then you know i guess
do a couple somersaults or you can
evolve and aim
you can scream and panic or you can aim
for those trees aim for the bushes yeah
aim for the bushes use your body as a
glider mechanism you know i've heard
like people have survived their shoots
failing like hitting falling into trees
and stuff so stories maybe maybe the
american revolutionaries had to fight a
war to seize their property back from
the king or basically
retain or gain the rights to their own
property that the king had seized from
them however you want to look at it and
to think that we might go back there is
really bothering me i don't like that
blackrock or blackstone has been able to
purchase uh yeah property i don't think
it should be constitutionally legal for
megacorps to buy property that doesn't
make sense to me maybe not single parent
single family homes but but
i i would say you hit the nail on the
head with the hammer um except for the
mite part i mean look at the rate at
which we're taxed
so
they were concerned about much less
taxes back then than we get taxed today
and it's getting worse
so man it's crazy to think about this
idea that after the american revolution
you owned land that was it you owned
land now you can't own land without
paying a million and one taxes i think
the the real indicator is whether we're
going to just into a civil war or not
and we've talked about this on red build
america a lot we've actually did an
episode on it we believe that we're
venturing towards that area we agree
with you on that i think the difference
is or what we're seeing right now if you
look at the american revolution or you
look at these the actual civil war in
the mid 1800s why did those things
happen they happened because the people
that were fighting didn't have political
recourse there was nothing that they
could do
from a political standpoint to change
the things that they were trying to
change in the in the 1776 it was they
didn't have you know taxation without
representation in the middle 1800s it
was oh you know we don't have rights
we're slaves
we're seeing are we seeing that now is
that what we're seeing is that there's
no political uh ability to solve our
problems that's the real question i
think that we're starting to ask
ourselves right now you know with people
talking about voter fraud and and those
kinds of things if people start to
believe that they do not have
the political pathway to solve their
problem they turn to violence and that
we've seen that throughout american
history so that's really the temperature
that we really need to be gauging is do
people feel that they can change things
in the voting booth those who make
peaceful revolution impossible make
violent revolution inevitable exactly so
if people
look
you've got uh we'll get into this in a
little bit but lindsey graham is
basically sabotaging the republicans
right before the election cool he's he's
pushing out this uh 15-week abortion ban
which is it's it's not going to pass
it's impossible the
republicans don't have the house the
senate or the executive branch so this
makes no sense to do
if people start to feel like there is no
path towards any kind of political
solution you're right they're going to
lose their minds and it's going to get
bad but i have to wonder if this is what
they want he right before a midterm
election get everybody riled up and
angry so that they can sabotage of
course it's what he he wants i believe
and i think that the people that are
going to be backing him on this i mean
culturally is is there anything
culturally that's pulling him into
making this decision i mean
it's that whole that old saying that
andrew breitbart made popular politics
is downstream of culture the only time
that you can
create polit or create a legislation
like this is if the culture asks for it
you can try to create it you could force
it down people's throats but the
decision already has to be made by the
american people for that to stand and
lindsey graham i think is off on this i
don't think culturally right now i mean
the whole thing with roby v wade and why
we were so happy about it i consider
myself pro-life but the reason why we
were so happy about it is because we
were throwing it back to the states and
we were allowing states to make their
decision and now he comes along and says
no now we're going to you know enforce
this on a federal level and i he has to
understand that this is going to rile up
the left he has to understand it i mean
just logics just logic will tell you
that he's a i i really i really am not a
big fan of that guy he's like a strong
arm authoritarian i don't know why he's
still in congress let's jump to this
story from insider
cardi b is furious about how expensive
everything has gotten how are people
surviving i want to know good question
uh cardi b is right
and i would say that cardi b man this is
this is probably a very important
barometer for the political temperature
in this country
when
establishment mainstream celebrities who
you know you mentioned in previous
segment they're supposed to be
with the left basically the left has
control the narrative democrats do when
they're coming out and being like nah
everything's bad and joe biden's
celebrating on the white house lawn
they're losing control it's getting it's
getting so hot out there it's getting so
crazy that regular people are starting
to say like yo this can't work
i think democrats should be particularly
worried about uh what happens in
november when you get prominent
celebrities being like hey this sucks
that's why they had i think this the
rally today is they know that their
backs are against the wall they're in
the corner on this they're trying to
gaslight everybody on the subject but
when you are touching cardi b on issues
like this and any kind of pop culture
icons like that i think that you uh
you're in serious trouble i agree with
you on that yeah regular people you
can't ignore it anymore now you're going
to get a whole bunch of people who are
going to be like yes queen like they
don't even know they don't even care all
they know is that she came out you know
we shouted out flecca's talks he has
these videos where they go and ask
people questions on the street on if
you've seen them yes and it's just that
people are just mind-numbingly dumb and
it's really disheartening but
while it is edited of course and i you
know i've done men in the street
interviews most people are not this
stupid what happens is they'll go out
they'll film a bunch of people and take
the stupidest ones and make a video and
it's kind of depressing but of those
dumb people that you see in those videos
they're the kind of people they're going
to hear they're going to hear cardi b
and go yeah it is bad i'm what i'm going
to vote how she says i've seen those
videos as well where they ask people to
ask you know who is this president or
who is our first president they can't
name them but they can also name every
single name of the kardashians right so
cardi b is going to to
to hit the right nerve on something like
this but i don't think how do you fight
how do you not see what is happening
right now i i don't think many people
pay attention i think that they're
relying on that and they're counting on
people to to not be paying attention to
what's you know the prices that are
happening right now it's way worse than
it is then it's being published because
they've changed the barometers for in to
calculate inflation if you use the same
numbers from the late 70s um it's worse
now it's way worse
it was it was and and that was just an
incredible time to live through the gas
lines that happened at that time the the
the prices were shooting up like crazy
interest rates we're complaining about
interest rates now interest rates got to
14 percent i think it was above 14
percent at that time like late 80s
wasn't it like 20 exactly exactly so i
mean we're complaining about it now
we're just getting into this right now
this inflation thing we're just
getting started on it fymar germany baby
yeah regarding people not paying
attention is this why like in the soviet
union they went after intelligentsia and
they tried to take that that strata out
is because those were the people that
could see the nonsense like they could
see the lie they were the dissidents
and that's why they why the left sees
the their arts and music and
and uh tv is is so valuable is because
they are the ones that are pushing that
message out there they start to lose
little strands like cardi b
and that you start to see the wall
breakdown and we're in an amazing time
like i don't want to put like fear porn
out there we live in a time now where
where shows like this exist where
barriers are being erased that were up
before
you know there was 20 years ago you
couldn't create a movie and hope to get
any distribution because there was no
streaming there was no the technology
wasn't there to to push that thing out
there we live in a time now where we can
actually just create something from our
iphone and put it out there into the
world so we have the tools to fight back
on this
but um but i think the left has
understood from a very i think this
there's a whole almost in conservatism
uh there's a fatal flaw in conservatism
and i consider myself a conservative
that um they haven't seen this coming
for many many years they allowed the
this to be this to happen they allowed
each one of these institutions to be
taken over i think there needs to be
some kind of a reformation uh movement
within the conservative movement to to
to grab to fully grasp this and you guys
are talking about it all the time i
praise you guys for doing that thank you
for doing that
you're surprisingly in the minority um
for the in the anti-woke world not a lot
of people talk about it they don't think
they feel like it's in their wheelhouse
when you talk about or or sometimes the
the metaphor fighting back in the
culture war comes up and but the
difference is in a real war and a hot
arms war you actually do fight back with
there's like devastation on both sides
and whoever gets destroyed the other
person wins but in a culture war the way
to win is to maintain positivity and to
include essentially everyone like you're
not shutting things down soon as you
start becoming the aggressor
the cultists don't want anything to do
with you so you have to stay almost like
ignorantly positive it's very
challenging for really intelligent
logical people because i think
when you look around you see things in
pain it's hard to ignore or pretend like
things are still really good but that's
what people want to hear and that's what
that's what taps into their feelings
everybody should play civilizations do
you ever play civilization video games
with sid meier civilization
uh they're on six right now and
there are several ways to win you know
you start as a nomadic tribe you build
cities eventually you have borders
eventually your boards are pressing
under people's borders brilliant game
i've been playing my whole life since
civilization too
and you can win through a cultural
victory if you have cultural dominance
over the planet everybody just wants to
be what you are you win the other thing
that can happen is if your culture is so
dominating it can actually
push the borders and annex cities and
other and other from other countries
so while it's a video game
understand this idea is rooted in real
life
when you start getting cultural
permeation when american culture starts
seeping in to say the soviet union
people then start demanding what other
people have you end up with a pizza
commercial with was it gorbachev and
he's like eating the pizza backwards and
then they're like he brought pizza hut
yay that's what happens when your
culture starts dominating other
countries your own citizens start saying
we don't like you we like them for
example when the war with ukraine broke
out
russian influencers were crying because
they were getting banned on instagram
so these are these are children of
russian officials with millions of
followers being like no my life i want
to be american that's a devastating
thing to destroy your country when your
own children are begging to be a part of
a different country i was getting the
vibe absolutely just really quickly
culture is key and i actually did what
you described before i had a picture of
kim kardashian and george washington and
i went to the streets of times square
and i was like who's who a lot of people
got the kardashians not a lot of people
got the president's and just one more
point before i let you go here um
another thing that i really wanted to
bring up specifically around this topic
is that i sacrificed my well-being and i
listened to this cardi b rant sorry on
instagram
and she does talk about how she helps a
lot of people and how even helping
people is is very difficult for her
because more and more people need help
now more than ever she talks about how
properties have gone up she talks about
how rents have gone up and she talks
about how do people deal if they don't
have a quote a cardi b in their life and
she legitimately asked that question she
made it about her she also addressed joe
biden and she said you know everyone's
coming at me because i supported joe
biden and i and i you know
campaigned for him and she said this is
happening all over the world this is
happening because of the pandemic and
she specifically addressed biden in this
to make sure that she was still okay in
the party establishment in the in the
kind of sphere so um but i don't know i
did it i wasn't happy i did it and i
listened to the rant no you should
people should listen you have to be
unhappy i think it was right of her for
her to call out all the problems we got
the story from tmz she visited her old
middle school and donated a hundred
grand i think cardi b is ready i think
that's fantastic i don't like the you
know her music but that's no that's no
big deal and she complained years ago
about taxes as well too
that was a big deal
my money you got it you gotta you gotta
you gotta you gotta sweet talk and be
like taxation is theft
and then could you imagine i think i
would sweet talk cardi b she comes out
she comes out with uh w-a-t-a-i-t
taxation
wet
did you see the clintons talk about that
the the oh no you don't want to see it
that just it's rich it'd just be tit
taxation yeah
those things never go well though what
was the
stephen colbert that did the the the
shot one where all the shots were
bouncing around like when you force
those kinds of messages in there but i
do see here but he wasn't self-aware
that's the problem like when you when
you know making a taxation is that the
song as a joke because you know it's
ridiculous yeah then it's funny but
colbert was serious
we can get cardi b though if we can pull
her over if she sees an ecosystem that
she can survive in and still do what she
does
but when she doesn't when you when we
all the time we get these little
percolations of people popping up macy
gray kind of coming out and saying i
know what a woman is a woman is da da da
and then having to a couple days later
completely backtrack from that because
she's afraid there are so many people in
hollywood that think about certain
topics the way that we would think and
we would kind of approach but they are
afraid because there's a monopolistic uh
industry that they're trying to operate
within we can only do so much but this
is why we're
making music for one i've made music my
whole life so we got carter banks who
also makes music that's what we can do
if i was a construction guy i'd start an
anti-well construction company you know
if i was a cartoonist that's what we'd
be doing sheamus he does that we need to
create a space where someone can
eventually be like i don't need to work
for you because you're woken insane that
other company is offering an opportunity
and i can go work there so i'm not
worried about speaking up 100 yeah i
think that cardi b is ready because i
remember her commenting about how she
felt like she hadn't genuinely been
herself since she became famous she said
if you're given the choice between
becoming rich or becoming famous just be
rich don't be famous it's terrible it's
stifling i was like oh it sounds like
you're ready for like a change of
scenery maybe we can make this happen
she's right though man yeah she's seeing
it she's seeing it i think she's gotten
to a level of success now where she is
uh you know seeing the world in a
different way and we just need to kind
of close the deal with people like that
yeah i i often talk about you know why
don't people do more there's so many
anti-woke people with power and wealth
and like what are they doing
they don't do that you wish they would
do more and then what you end up seeing
is people like mackenzie bezos takes
billions of dollars from her divorce
settlement and then invests in critical
race theory gender theory all this woke
stuff and i'm just like where where are
the
you know the anti-woke the libertarian
and the right with massive i mean luke
how many bitcoin millionaires do you
know and where are they at what are they
doing huh why aren't they making tv
shows working in mcdonald's now
i think a lot of people do get involved
but a lot of people are also afraid to
get involved um i think the culture that
we're living in is one where they try to
scare people from not speaking out not
getting involved and i i think that's
the biggest aspect of control that the
system and establishment has on everyone
else is this kind of paranoia is this
low vibrational fear that keeps them in
control and keeps them from being able
to fully express themselves and live
their truest lives so
there is a big aspect of it that we need
to show people hey it's safe out there
everything's fine it's okay you could
even confront a politician you could you
could you could cuss them out and you
could tell them out you could tell them
exactly how you feel you could you could
speak your truths and it'll be okay and
it'll be fine and the world would be a
better place if people would just stop
pretending that they're somebody else
and that they should be okay and that
they should be in the confines of what
they think is okay and not i think
that's the biggest fallacy we're facing
there's a real problem with fame like
like you were saying who was it that oh
was it cardi and steve martin said the
same thing if you could be rich or
famous just take rich don't be famous
it's the brave people come in here and
they're like tim you're brave like
that's what being famous if you don't
have the money to have six armed guards
surrounding you like a hexagon at all
times like which is insane anyway no one
does no one really does that like dude
it's
this culture of crowds and mobs that
form around someone because they love
them or they hate them mobs can go
haywire really fast if there's an
explosion or if someone screams or if if
a boulder falls down the hill like that
alone that's the non-emotion like it's
dan there is a danger of being famous
yeah
go for it that's about it i wanted to
say like
you know i remember when i was younger
and people would say things same thing
if you could choose what you're famous
be rich
i remember i was on a rooftop in
illinois with a bunch of like investors
and like local politicians for some
reason don't ask me i have no idea i
ended up there and they were saying like
the biggest mistake people make is they
think you know being fame is a path to
something in reality it's exposure it's
risk and i was i was thinking about that
especially now because we have like just
a plethora of stalkers
both love and hate pleather yeah and
love and hate it's both extremely
dangerous then you also have you have
different kinds of stalkers you have the
hater stalkers who make things up and
are insane and just like think i'm
stealing their spoons there was somebody
who tweeted that i went to their house
thousands of miles away at two in the
morning and turned their tvs on and woke
them up and then the other the other
stalkers all believe it because they're
just genuinely nuts but then you have
the stepping stone stalkers people who
think that they too can be rich and
famous if only they could get you
to give them the chance or give them
money and then you it just it's just
it's it's it's an it's a crazy
experience it's a crazy discovery
and i got to tell you man you read these
stories about what happens when people
win the lottery and how everyone comes
out of the woodwork oh bro it is worse
than people the stories you hear when
people talk about the stalkers
these celebrities don't tell you the
truth about how bad the stalking really
is because it would make it worse but
i'll tell you whatever you think is
going on with these celebrities and
these stalker stories it's actually 100
times worse substantially worse yeah i
wish we could put together like a
documentary and just show exactly how
bad it is we've been swatted 13 times
13
and where's the fbi
no idea there's not what can they really
do and it still just gets crazier the
bigger this show gets the more
successful we are the crazier things
have gotten from my experience is one of
the best things you could do is not to
give these people any attention because
that's usually what they're after and
that's what they love they love getting
an impact they love being heard about
they love being talked about so i dealt
with this for a while it's not
convenient but it's the price we pay and
uh to add to to to your comment ian what
you were saying about the groups and
going crazy frederick nietzsche had a
perfect comment about this when he said
in individuals insanity is rare but in
groups parties and nations it is the
rule and i think when he said that he
hit the nail on the head to what's
happening right now in the larger
microcosm of american politics i think
people are suffering i think we're
dealing with a nutritional health crisis
i think we're dealing with a financial
crisis i think we're dealing with a
cultural crisis i think the crap that
they're putting out as entertainment
that really is propaganda is just
unwatchable in many instances it's
disgusting in many instances and i think
we're seeing the unraveling of our
society and hopefully something new
comes from all of this and new people
come in with better ideas and
don't create a great reset as some
people would say but but build out of
the old something new something better
because we need it more than ever
they're going to try and push central
bank currencies um and they're going to
switch us from proof of work to proof of
stake for the crypto so instead of
having proof of work which is the more
processor power you have to make your
bitcoins it's going to be proof of stake
the more bitcoin you own the more money
you're going to make so they're trying
to move us to a rich get richer system
with proof of stake it's it's very
dystopian it's really annoying and
they're going to try and do the mass
censorship
i don't know man let's
go for it let's jump to this next story
man
from tvline.com emmys hits all time
audience low good wow good the end is
nice did you watch it i i didn't even
know what happened yeah i didn't know i
watched it for those of you that are
saying right now send in your chats at
super chats did you know the emmys even
happened like one or two i did not know
i had no clue it was not in anyone's
feeds i mean you would see the you know
typically the clips nobody was tweeting
about it i watched it because i feel
like i have to watch those kinds of
things it was i'm sorry you had to do
that
there was a moment where i told my wife
adriana i'm like we can't do this she
says no no we got to keep watching
it was a cringe fest just one thing
after the other just caught it's so
infused into ev and saturated just it's
just saturated into everything that they
do the awards they give the shows they
give
shows that should have easily won were
lost out to the most woke show i mean
it's just i think it's just part of
that why the reason why those ratings
are so low that's we have such a great
opportunity right now well i kind of
think that uh
the system is collapsing
and it's more apparent uh to me than i
think to the average person for a few
reasons
i don't know if it's going to recover so
we got a bunch of times square
billboards we did this over the summer
we we went nuts we had like 25 ads just
like dominating the space was awesome
and a lot of people were like that's
crazy how could you afford that and then
i'm just like bro it costs 20 bucks to
run ahead in times square
one time
yeah so like
and you can get even cheaper there's
some some smaller ads like still big
screens like seven dollars and they'll
say like you got to buy at least 20 of
them or whatever so it's a couple
hundred bucks and then it'll run for the
day
that's a lot cheaper than people realize
and the reason
you know it's done like the foot traffic
is down
these there's no impact anymore there's
no cultural references there's like
there's no cultural cohesion so even
having the ads doesn't do anything it's
just a statement being made and i
thought about it i'm like here we are we
did it we we're here in the center of
american culture
and we made our point
but we were only able to because the
system has decayed to the point where
the it used to be that there's so many
big companies with tens of millions of
dollars that they were all competing for
these spaces the prices were super high
now nobody wants them now they're debt
like some of the billboards in there are
turned off
so so yeah off interesting and i'm like
hey that one that's off can i get that
one we ended up getting the entire
billboard to ourselves
so we also ended up hitting number two
on billboard digital sales
and you know what you know we sold 12
520 songs in one week that's number two
twelve thousand interesting that's it
interesting it used to be 100 200 500
000 so now i get it we're in a different
kind of economy with streaming music
but
it's not just about uh you know nobody's
encouraging i mean you can check this
out to the rental economy and you will
own nothing and you'll be happy but my
point is we are able to stand atop the
ruins
we're able to be like look how well
we're doing only because the system has
collapsed like if we had a show this big
10 years ago we would not be getting top
you know singles and music or times
square but because the system has just
broken down and fallen apart we can
climb on the rubble and be like i am
king of the rubble and everyone's like
yeah
and then we're like ha ha
those would have gone for tens of
thousands of dollars
that you could not get out of an ad for
less than a hundred thousand dollars for
something well so like if you want to
get the biggest
the big tower you know they do it on
like a week by week basis and it's like
600 grand per week
but most of the billboards you know
they're big but they're not that big
it's like
you can have a run
all day for a couple grand and you can
actually schedule like 20 ad placements
to span over one you know one day over
you know they'll play like once every
other minute for a few hours and it'll
cost you 200 bucks
it's just that the demand is gone not
not only that but like small businesses
have been wiped out so ad revenue is
collapsing i just i look at the emmys
and it's like
american culture is being erased these
things that we used to
all
be interested in and talk about just
gone and without that what happens you
end up i'll just say
in a big civil war
because when you have completely
disparate cultures that don't like each
other that don't care about each other
and aren't concerned about offending
each other they can say whatever they
want about each other it used to be that
you were like
okay i better not say that you know what
what's the famous apocryphal quote from
michael jordan conservatives buy shoes
too
right why don't you get uh conservatives
buy shoes too man nowadays it's like i
don't want their money anyway so i'll
rag on them and hopefully that'll make
more of the woke left by my stuff or the
or the inverse now you've got democrats
or republicans refusing to debate each
other
you've got katie hobbs she won't debate
carrie lake but you got uh who is it
herschel walker is that his name he's
not gonna debate uh um
warnock there you go
and so the the reality is what's to be
gained the hyper polarization is so
intense you only face risk by actually
coming together there so a republican is
going to come out and be like i'm not
going to get any of these democrat votes
why bother talking to him and the
democrats going back i'm not going to
get a republican vote why bother talking
to him because it's not even about the
the policy it's about democrats are
better or republicans are bad in which
case it is what it is the chips have
fallen where they're going to fall let's
see who wins the election
everything is fractured and it is sooner
or later
people are going to just demonize each
other to the point where they're
fighting in the streets i mean it
probably already happened it's like
already happening actually we're seeing
it i mean i don't know if it's just
because of social media that we're
seeing so much more of this kind of
violence happening or you know in los
angeles i mean
you can't go a day without seeing a
somebody walk into a restaurant while
people are eating with a gun and putting
a gun to their head and taking money
from them i think you're right the
social cohesion there is no
what event on a national scale now is
considered something that is kind of
must-see that's this cultural kind of
phenomenon that brings everybody
together even nfl even the nfl now is
broken down i mean we we the the whole
advertising thing was used to be a huge
thing where we would sit down and watch
the advertisements which advertisement
is the best and now it's just we're
constantly being bombarded with the
wokeness on any of these things so
there's no cohesion there's no culture
and a lot of that had to do i believe
with this illegal immigration problem
that we've been dealing with now since
at least the 70s where there is no
there's a there's no entry that where
people have to say okay this is what
american is and this is what i bought
into and i'm going and i'm signing on to
this i am buying into the american
dream into the american culture into the
what it means to be american we've lost
that entirely we lost it through pledge
of allegiances in schools where we used
to sing these kinds of things on a
regular basis when i was growing up now
you don't see those kinds of things
happen so much anymore
we've lost this cultural cohesion and i
think that you're right it is leading to
more and more violence and social media
is helping instigate it and trigger it
even more the next big thing to just
shatter and destroy american culture
will be when they have
in like the nfl and the nba force
diversity when they say stuff like hey
these rules are arbitrary why don't we
mandate that half the team be women
sooner or later it's gonna happen
has already hit sports and the weird
left call has already hit sports sooner
or later they're going to come out and
be like you know we made these rules up
right it's discriminatory that your team
is all male
yes and then you're going to have the
nba it's like can be half men and half
women and it's going to be the sport
you're going to be the one doing all the
work so much harder to get away with it
in sports i just saw another meme
because i referenced the memes you're
talking about i saw a meme where this
woman broke the the deadlifting record
and it was
634 pounds or something and then
somebody quickly followed that up with
yeah a man's record is 1100 pounds i
mean there's so the difference between
men and women when it comes to these
kinds of things i mean and women have
their thing i prefer watching women
tennis than men's tennis because they're
rallying it's just a little bit more of
an exciting game to watch so there's not
to say there isn't a place for women in
sports what have you but the difference
between the the sexes when it comes to
sports that's just drastic i think the
tennis thing you know i i don't really
mind i think it's entertaining when it's
like serena or who's that other guy uh
when they smash their their racket and
scream and enrage
that's what we're here for everybody
knows nobody actually enjoys watching
tennis we're just waiting for them to
smash their racket it's like i'm kidding
by the way but it's like nascar they say
that everyone's just waiting for a car
to crash or something and i'm like no
not really
you know because that i i don't think
that happens all the time
but yeah man uh
so so according to this tv line article
it says
that emmys hit the an all-time audience
low opposite the most watched monday
night football since oh nine i think i
think they're saying monday night
football right yeah
mnf yeah who was it was that the browns
i don't know but uh i was talking to
somebody about the state of culture and
media a while ago and they said that
sports will be the last to go
because sports is something that can't
be rerun like you can watch an old game
to see what's up but for the most part
you need the live here and now show for
what matters
with tv shows
i'm watching breaking bad right now i'm
on season five
and it's a it's a ten year old show so
most people already seen it but but i'm
like oh i'm saying if i haven't seen
it's new to me yeah you were saying i
can't we can't you can't go watch old
nfl games and be like like you could i
guess you were saying you watched the
emmys patrick and i was like uh my
thought was did you watch it on 1.5
speed because i have no interest but
that would mean you had to wait till
it's already done to go back and watch
it
we watched it there's just no
there's no rush to the show anymore
because i'd rather watch it later faster
it just didn't it didn't represent
america and the american experience at
all and they've gone overboard you know
the whole thing with the the oscars so
white i think hollywood really took that
to heart and it honestly it felt like we
were watching the bet awards it was just
this crazy recorrection and i've talked
to
screenwriters about this the way
hollywood is they're getting fed up with
it they can't work anymore and we're
talking about very successful
showrunners of huge shows on hbo and nbc
and what have you that they and i've
been hearing this complaint since 2012.
so this has been going on for 10 years
there where they cannot get work if
their skin is white
and so you're seeing that this this
constant infiltration in hollywood
that's why we keep going on keep going
back to the same thing we're we're we
have a great this gold rush right now in
regards to being able to get in there
and make stuff because people are dying
for it let's jump to this uh story from
bounding into comics wait before we do
that there's also some breaking news
people are talking about in the chat
room
my pillow guy getting raided by the fbi
what yeah this is so so this is the
story that's coming out right now that
he was tracked down by the fbi on a
hunting trip surrounded in his car and
had his cell phone seized so that's the
story that some people in the chat room
have been letting me know i just wanted
to bring it up at in at a point where we
didn't kind of move on for
uh the next story but uh well let's pull
this out let's pull this up from the
daily beast
mike lindell fed seized my cell phone at
hardee's
at hardee's hearties where's this guy
can a man enjoy a burger where is he
just near hearties lindell also posted a
subpoena in what appears to be a search
warrant
so this is breaking news my pillow's ceo
mike lindell told the daily beast on
tuesday night that the fbi seized his
cell phone while he was at a hardy's
restaurant he posted on social media a
grand jury subpoena from a federal
prosecutor in colorado who appears to be
a search warrant the fbi had no
immediate comment so well i don't know
man what else can be said
it's it's it's it's the system's busted
it's falling apart
they are looking to do what they did to
nixon and all of his uh crew and his
cohorts you know we're right now we're
doing a multiple part series on nixon
and it's fascinating the parallels
between what's happening in that right
now with trump and all the trump circle
and what happened to nixon
back in the day and the more that they
can dirty everyone that's around him
they scare people from getting involved
within the community within his culture
within within his uh
circle of politics they they dirty him
up to be able to go and run for a next
election i think that's what this entire
thing is about it's the narrative
machine in action scare everybody that's
associated with trump he's gonna have a
hard time getting good people because of
that
constantly paint him and any associate
that he has as a criminal you don't
think that we're gonna see perp walk
ads ads when the when the election comes
oh yeah we are going to see perp walk
ads they are going and i said this uh
back in the jan 6 time frame that trump
we're going to see trump perp walked and
people thought that it was nuts when i
said that
it's not going to happen he is going to
get perp walked they want that image so
they could put it whether it stands or
not it doesn't whether it doesn't matter
it's the image we got a video here we
got a video here of uh mike lindell
so uh we will play this video i think
this might be the video today the fbi
all right let's let's quiet let's quiet
that down a little bit mike you're
pretty loud
sorry about that
today the fbi
uh you're gonna hear this and you're
probably already hearing in the news the
fbi
came after me and took my phone they
surrounded me at a hardee's
and uh took my phone i run all my
business everything with um
um they could have just what they've
done is weaponized the fbi um
it's disgusting i don't have a computer
everything i do up that phone everything
was on there and uh
um
and they told me not to tell anybody
here's an order not to don't tell
anybody okay i won't
i am
so
they've walked steve bannon over a
million bucks yep blm has been accused
of stealing more than that the the
leaders the founders and stuff like that
uh nothing
in the and wasn't he pardoned i mean uh
how is that like we're in a civil war
so uh
you know what no no i should take that
back we're in a revolution civil war
implies that there's factions fighting
each other but right now the fbi is just
rounding people up and it's and it
appears to be extra legal yeah there's
an attempted revolution from the liberal
award order to the new world order i
gotta say that clearly liberal world
order to a new world order and that
seems like some people in the american
government are complicit i mean i don't
have proof i just seems like that's
that's that's that's a bit beyond where
i'm at i'm just saying the democrats
don't want to lose they want power
they're scared of trump and they've
weaponized the doj to go after anybody
who might help trump we saw this in 2018
when the big tech company started
banning prominent influencers who helped
trump win notably alex jones they purged
him all the exact same time
alex jones is now on trial again for
defamation and it's like it seems to be
going the same way they're like oh
you're not a lot of defense and things
like that you're you're refusing to you
know send out you know to turn over
proper information now they're going
after steve bannon said there's 35
prominent trump supporters you know
dark days is an understatement
if i don't i don't know what happens
but typically when you look at history
and you see things like this we're
looking at probably something more like
a bolshevik style revolution
i mean maybe maybe that's that's that's
too much but what's likely more likely
than civil war at this point is just
uniparty arrests the purging of
political rivals
the evisceration of anyone who's
supporting the ideology and just a
totalitarian uniparty so you know
you can have a civil war when two
factions fight over control of one
government or in the united states it
was one faction trying to leave a
government or you can have a revolution
where one group seizes control uses it
to immediately purge and wipe out their
opponents and then take over
tucker carlson called this a full-blown
political purge
and he he's not wrong i mean look at
what's happening here i mean what what
what will the mike my pillow guy do to
you what kind of threat is he to you who
is he going to hurt what did he do what
did he do what did he get away with he's
got money i know but but from the
average person watching this who's not
into politics seeing this right now a
lot of people are asking themselves this
question obviously this is very
political but but they're still trying
to say that this is this is somehow
justified that the doj is going after
bad people that they're going after
criminals but there's not even a shred
of evidence to suggest this because from
the average point of view what effect is
he having like what did they steal
something no they didn't they didn't get
away with anything were they able to to
to lie or cheat and no they don't
there's no there's nothing of that i
think this is a large fishing operation
i think they're looking for whatever
they could get and
going through someone's phone going
through someone's self of cell phones
and laptops and computers and all of
their documents they're just hoping
someone slipped up and made some kind of
mistake and if they did we're going to
be hearing about it till the end of days
now seems like oh we're going and
they're also trying to scare advertisers
as well too he's one of the biggest kind
of advertiser known advertiser on the
right funds a lot of different shows a
lot of different podcasts and they're
trying to send a message out there as
well that you know if you guys try to
enter into this arena if you guys try to
appeal to the right we're going to come
at you a lot of people don't we don't
talk about this so much but how how
completely
leftist the advertising community is
they they have control the digital
platforms that are that distribute these
advertisements they've gotten
conservative
websites kicked off of these uh
advertising networks for years and years
and years so there's so many different
things kind of in play here they want
everyone that's trump that touched trump
to look dirty they want to scare
advertisers to scare away funding for
shows uh it's it's a really a smart play
if you think about it these people that
we're dealing with are not stupid they
understand the imagery they understand
what it means to have o'bannon walk to
akshmiban and walk down perp-walked they
understand the power of the imagery
they've been doing this since this since
the civil rights era getting pictures of
you know dogs in front of civil rights
activists and and hoses being shot on
them so i think that's what what this is
doing they're they're they're feeding
their narrative machine with this stuff
so they can scare the the right yeah i
always get in the sense that it's the
people that were saying that the
election was stolen and that they have
proof but like then the proof never came
out and they're like it's coming just
wait three months and then it'll be
there lindell and bannon are really hard
on that they're really bush um but what
i don't get is who cares like let him
say it like that's part of democracy
we're allowed to yell stuff at each
other biden's the president let's secure
the elections by having open source
voting systems they did it for four
years with the russians with the russian
accusations with trump when trump
won and and now like
i just it's just mind-boggling to see
what's happening here because it's so
dangerous for everyone involved here i
wasn't a trump supporter i didn't i
didn't back him i criticized him but but
still it doesn't matter to a lot of
people because now even calling this out
automatically labels me as some kind of
trump supporter when i'm not that's the
point that and that's the other side of
it yes i was ready to walk um be past
trump i was a trump supporter i was
ready to be done
then all this stuff starts to hit and
all they're doing is pulling these
people out that were done with him and
ready to move on to a desantis or what
have you they're pulling them back in
they pulled me back in
in that regard
i'm not sure if it's the right play or
but they they think they know what
they're doing
administration has politicized law
enforcement to the point
where it feels soviet and we were not
overstating it the fbi has just raided
the guy who sells pillows on this
channel not because the pillows were bad
but because they don't like who we voted
for would be funny if the fbi was like
well the pillows actually are really
good use promo code
use promo code fbi yeah promo code gulag
tucker your ghouls known as the pillow
guy reports on his live stream lindell
tv that fbi agents located him
questioned him showed him their badges
and asked him questions about colorado
and dominion voting machines and then
provided him with a warrant to seize his
cell phone
and he says uh we're fbi i said show me
your badges
so they showed one battery i said how
about yours you know i'm you know i
don't trust anybody like you know
there's bad people well they do that and
they said what do you want
and uh says we need to talk to you so i
pull over
and uh
mike lindell said he initially told
those agents he would not surrender his
phone because he does not have a
computer and runs all of his businesses
off of that phone lindell published on
his live stream what he claims was the
warrant for that phone we do not have
lindell's account confirmed right now
but we will be looking into it and
keeping you updated tucker
so maybe it's maybe it's bunk i don't
know but um i kind of believe the pillow
guy
like this is a story i don't think he
just makes up especially considering
bannon came out said 35 people were hit
then we got official confirmation that
40 subpoenas had been sent out the
subpoenas probably included mike lindell
why wouldn't they i mean he's one of the
most vocal supporters of donald trump he
also funded didn't he fund some kind of
a program to look into the election
fraud and what have you he did a big
symposium or something about it tucker
actually talked about the people who are
named on that list last night and he
talked about one person who organized a
rally and how the fbi raided the
daughter of this person who organized a
rally and how
they weren't even involved in politics
they were already involved in
politicians they were just someone
involved in uh getting people to do
political rallies and they are the they
were the ones that were raided by fbi
officials coming at their door knocking
on their door and of course
intervening in their life and watching
every single move they make very
carefully and you know the information
especially with how the dog has been
recently handling it most likely is
going to be leaked to the media as of
course there's a lot of things that
routinely are not supposed to make it
out there to the general public through
these investigations that do that smear
people that attack people
there's phone records there's text
messages there's there's things about
individuals personal lives that always
make it out there and this is the
weaponization of the doj that of course
um is going out there and going after
people that they don't like because of
their political opinions and ideas i
don't even agree with those political
opinions and ideas but this is such a
dangerous move because it endangers
everyone here this is meant to set a
chilling factor
and uh it is scaring some people
if you ever wondered what it was like to
be living in uh you know any one of
these historical nations before the
emergence of the
authoritarian regimes be it north korea
or weimar germany or russia or china or
whatever you're living in it
this is how it starts
and uh man i really gotta wonder i
wonder if um
the kovid lockdowns were kind of uh
a dry run will people submit to
unconstitutional lockdowns in the
destruction of their lives and they
found the answer was yes overwhelmingly
it was nuts how the roman republic just
turned into an empire you go from a
republic to an empire that seems really
extreme i was just reading about the
british monarchy and the king you know
it's hot topic right now and like
he can take control he can disband
parliament i mean
they say he won't because elizabeth
never did but he can and all he's got to
do is claim emergency but like what's an
emergency a flood an earthquake uh
someone saying the wrong thing on social
media spilling your tea
yeah the way they've used the word
emergency these days like how many
emergency acts has biden
uh going right now we have like 45
states of emergency or some we were
looking up some numbers some over like
25 or current um
yeah yeah tons of emergencies mostly
foreign policy i think yeah and some of
it's like about iraq you're like what
the hell we've been out of iraq like
what emergency are we as american
citizens facing because of what's
happening in that country and so if they
if the king were to seize power and
become the the sole monarch of england
all of britain all of a sudden and then
they they try and emulate that over here
with try yeah i know they're disturbing
it doesn't
but i mean it's not it's totally
possible it's feasible that's the
problem california is still in a state
of emergency to this day
it's it still has that because they do
not want to relinquish the power the
second that they were able to imp
implement this power this power grab and
we've seen it time and time again
anytime these you know the bushes did it
with the patriot act anytime these power
this power is given to the government
they never let go of it and the thing
that's been the difference is is that
the right is not as good at
enforcing their their power the left is
our masters at it they have figured out
ways to be able to
to use the government in ways that
they've accused trump of doing when
trump was in office
let's pull up this story here from
timcast.com
senator lindsey graham proposes
nationwide 15-week abortion ban grams of
the legislation is comparable to
abortion regulations in 47 european
countries the republicans don't have the
senate the house or the executive branch
so there's no point in introducing this
bill other than to virtual signal or
sabotage the republicans right before
the midterm election
i mean you can argue that maybe he's
like
look we're gonna do this
if you vote for us we will do this
because that will rally not just
democrats but also republicans but
republicans are already angry they're
already ready to vote out democrats
democrats are the ones who need to be
riled up
so it seems like lindsey graham is just
sabotaging the republicans i think he's
an insulated guy like he's insulated in
his his you know
echo chamber and thinks that he's doing
moral good by his what he believes that
he really believes and wants that i i
don't i don't agree with you he's an
establishment neocon that has been
always toting the line of the party
establishment no matter what it is and
he always is on the tip of the sphere
when it comes to pushing this larger
agenda that screws everyone else over it
wouldn't surprise me if this was a
bigger play to screw over uh you know
the big part of the republican party
that is set to allegedly win in this
upcoming election you look at how you
know the abortion ruling by the supreme
court mobilized a whole bunch of
activists a whole bunch of people to get
active inside of democratic states and
cities all throughout the united states
why bring up this issue when of course
this is only showing the enemy your move
even if it's that but i don't think it's
that i think it's what tim is asserting
it is and i think this is a deliberate
action to shoot in the foot the kind of
populist uprising that he wants to quail
so he you think he he wants trump or any
republican to fail so that the unit the
liberal economic order can seize control
and so he's just shoving a nail in it
with this well this is going to mobilize
i think a lot of people and i think if
you look at his voting record it's
always been not just you know republican
uh or democratic it's always been pro
establishment pro ruling party pro
billionaire class pro world economic
forum he has always voted along those
particular lines so it wouldn't surprise
me if he's now intervening as many
people like joe rogan are telling people
to go vote republican
and i think this is going to have an
effect on it
it's habitat you're right on that yeah
if you think that someone would sabotage
their own political party is very very
weird but he's not really he's not
aligned with the populist republicans
he's aligned with with the democrats
he's had a history of that i mean look
at uh liz cheney i mean she's a
republican she's uh
is there anybody that has uh sabotaged
the the maga movement more or tried to
sabotage the maga movement more than her
i mean i think he is an establishment
guy that tends to go along like mccain
did
with the democrats on certain kinds of
issues and this just doesn't make any
sense it goes against the entire
argument for roe v wade and getting rid
of it was to give this off to the states
and allow states to make up their own
mind on this that was the argument from
the right and now he's completely
usurping that he's saying no we actually
want more than that and to do this right
now before an election i mean does he
have some kind of polling numbers that
say something different i don't know i
think we saw what happened in kansas
when they put it on the bill they put an
amendment i think it was kansas was yeah
it was kansas where they put a the
abortion bill on their amendment ended
getting vote voted down resoundingly
voted down he's helping democrats that
simple 100 because now every single
democrat is going to have campaign ads
saying senator lindsey graham
wants a nationwide
abortion ban
and they got it i guess if you if like
cultural military you know war gaming
here if you had a country and there was
a a revolt in one of your cities and you
couldn't get the r the rebels out of
your city that you would scorch dirt the
city and burn it all down even though
it's your city so if he's afraid that
the magga have taken over the republican
party that he would sabotage the
republican party that's not out of the
realm of possibility no it's not and if
they if they do not have the red wave
that so many on the right are hoping for
what does that say
who who ends up benefiting from that i
think it ends up being you know i think
trump ends up not benefiting from that
and the establishment republicans they
like they've done with illegal
immigration for years they misrepresent
or they misinterpret
an election outcome to benefit their own
positions and they've done it with
illegal immigration in the past where
where somebody would lose and they'd say
okay that was because they took a hard
line against illegal immigration we need
to go amnesty the way that the left is
doing and and lindsay is a perfect
example of of somebody that's completely
bought into this establishment lindsey
is also really good friends with joe
biden and again said that joe biden is a
good man as quote as god has ever
created so he's been very anti-trump
very anti-populist very pro-uh john
mccain neocon neoconservative trying to
start foreign wars every chance every
instance he gets so he's definitely not
working in the interest of the american
people he's working towards the interest
of the military-industrial complex and
the ruling party since you know the
connection with biden is very clear with
him and uh you know biden being in the
senate you know for 720 years now
uh they had a very long cozy
relationship yeah he was in the roman
senate yeah it's true yeah
i i wonder if lindsay was bullied when
he was a kid because it kind of feels
like this is what someone that's like
the target of being bullied grows up and
then they get power and now then they
become a bully what's the problem with
bullying man right just an evil guy you
know just evil
man
you know in my younger days i did not
believe in good and evil
i was just like no i think it's it's you
know people are trying their best but
they just disagree on how you go about
things and then you get into
you know an industry industry like this
you're like oh no they're evil
they're literally just even crazy things
when people believe they're doing good
because like everybody thinks they're
the hero in their own story so when
people believe they're doing good while
they're doing evil acts it's really good
that's easy but but i but i think
some of them just evil like they they i
used to think that i used to think
everybody was the hero of their own
story and then i was like wow and then
you have to realize no some people are
evil some of them are just like how much
collateral damage can we sustain it they
told me that she said occupy wall street
they said don't you want to just watch
it all burn and i said not really and
they're like i was thinking about 911.
and if that really was perpetrated by
someone other than who we think it was
or even even if there was more
involvement than what we were told that
they're like how many people can we kill
and destroy in order to get a war going
so that we can start profiting in the
middle east so it's beyond that and i
think when we talk about a larger
spiritual energetic war i think there's
more reality to this that's very hard to
quantify in words because there are
individuals in our society just like the
new uh science advisor in the in the in
the biden administration that literally
takes all of his human liquids and
writes demonic words on walls with them
in order to summon demons and does
things like spirit cooking
with
podesta uh podesta uh tony podesta
that's john's brother he's pretty crazy
i've heard yeah there's john podesta of
course you know my favorite cooking my
favorite meme paintings was the uh
police sketch of the people who
kidnapped that little girl and it just
you not seen this oh yeah i've seen this
yeah the police sketcher like here's the
peop
people of interest in the in the case of
this missing young girl and it looks
just like the podesta brothers yes
exactly like that yeah like there's even
a mole on the face it's like that's
weird yeah tony john's brother john just
got tapped for biden's what is he what's
his position now in the body
administration john's in there now you
remember what what breitbart said
what did you say you guys don't know no
you guys don't know what mike said yeah
about podesta uh-huh but tony tony has
been known to be like a wild wild one
yeah and that's john he can't control
what your brother does but that's still
like you know i don't know how connected
they have a consulting group that of
course andrew breitbart tweeted february
4th 2011
how prague guru john podesta isn't a
household name as world-class underage
sex slave op cover-up or defending
unspeakable dregs escapes oh my wow
that's a lot very crazy thing for a man
to say that's like back in the day when
no one knew who podesta was when you're
connected to the secretary of state like
he was with hillary you've got access to
all the information of what's going on
he might have known if tony was doing
stuff and like what do you it's his
brother so like well do you have your
brother arrested i mean in a just
society yes but in a nepotistic thing
you you know we see maybe not well they
they ran a consulting group together
that worked with a lot of foreign
governments that worked with saudi
arabia that worked with a lot of death
spots um and if you look at the the work
that they've done it's it's really kind
of scary and eye-opening how much
influence that they had they were pretty
much the right-hand man for hillary
clinton and bill clinton and uh those
are some dirty hands to have john
podesta was yeah uh yes john podesta
specifically i i interviewed john
podesta uh before uh he's also big into
aliens and ufos lots of weird stuff with
him and the paintings and the art that
they have we could go down the rabbit
hole what if what if the reality is that
uh
aliens just you know run things aliens
and and that explains everything that's
the next false fight according to eddie
bravo every one of these politicians are
aliens they've been allowed to stay in
this for too long not every year
and there are aliens who are like we run
this you're a chicken coop and you do as
you're told yeah
and then you're going to say i really
believe this media matters but they've
been in power for too
long i was doing we did this thing
recently where we're looking for clips
from the 1972 election and i'm looking
at election night uh footage and who's
who are they talking about joe biden
yeah 1972
50 years ago this guy has been in this
and when you're in dc for that long you
understand all the loopholes all the ins
and outs the positions that you need to
make money to to flow money to the big
guy to how to get your family in there
and and and bifurcate you know
investigations and what have you there
are smart people that have been in in dc
for a very long time that have become
evil this is my fun conspiracy theory
joke
that uh
the answer to fermi's paradox is that
aliens do exist they did come here
they've taken over and the reason we're
seeing such weird and rapid changes to
our culture and society is because the
point at which they began is the point
at which the aliens showed him and said
all right we're taking over you can't
stop us we have laser guns
and then the world leaders were like
well okay i guess a good example of um
the fun thought
is an episode of stargate
sg1 where
for those that are familiar with it
basically there's a planet
it's very advanced and then the people
living there don't realize that they had
already been secretly conquered by the
the evil alien race or whatever and so
everything seems to be normal but then
they find out actually the government
was being run by an invading species or
whatever so you know fun fun conspiracy
are the aliens just having fun with us
no no like you know i was thinking you
know you guys are familiar with fermi's
paradox yes
so what is that
yeah explain that really quick so it's
basically if the universe is so vast and
expansive then alien life surely must
exist and if so why haven't we
encountered it here are the potential
theories or hypotheses as to why we've
encountered intelligent life and there's
things like the great filter which is
that any sufficiently intelligent life
eventually wipes itself out there's um i
forgot i forgot what some of the names
of these are but some of them are that
sun's basically bursting beforehand you
know cataclysmic events that take out
well that's that's basically the great
filter like life gets wiped out but
there's also things like um the universe
is so big and so vast that life never
appears at the same time as each other
and or it's or it's so incredibly rare
uh so there's a bunch of different ideas
and my hypothetical answer is that uh
aliens are abundant and considering the
size and scope of the universe mastering
massive uh hyper hyper speed travel and
uh we are a bunch of monkeys on a on a
small primitive planet and so they are
we're a chicken coop i don't see why
aliens would have to be our size i could
imagine that they're larger than our
solar system yeah or smaller yeah and
and we're we're beast of burden you know
what i mean they need they need
specialists with with digits that can
you know build little hardware and stuff
for them so it sounds like what you're
saying because there is the one of the
biggest and earliest media hoaxes was in
the early 1800s where they i think it
was the new york sun did an article on
the moon having uh batman
and uh
it was huge they did like all of these
stories on it and they cited some
some london uh study
and to validate this so it sounds to me
like what you're saying is is that story
was actually not a hoax that somehow i'm
just kidding
like i think the reality is corrupt
people do corrupt things and burn
everything to the ground like we're
tracking like the roman empire you know
it's it's similar and so we can look to
history and say hey things like this
just happen you know i was thinking
today would you let yourself die to make
everyone else's life better do you think
would you do that today i i have a hard
time saying yes to that because i'm like
those people what did they do for me
what do i like the collective personal
if you said okay this family member this
dot your daughter or your wife for a
second i've actually seen a video on
this recently where they basically asked
women that question would you die
for your
husband
or for your boyfriend and to a tea i
know this edited so maybe they didn't
all say that but every single one of
them said no i would not and the man
said they asked the men and all of the
men said yes well come on look i got
chickens outside
and if a fox is lurking up the rooster
will run full speed sacrificing its life
to save the hens and the hens will all
go run to safety yeah he'll die yeah
that's just the way nature is man that's
why it's what is i got a question though
do you guys think
that if you knew the the collapse the
roman empire was coming would you as an
individual be able to have stopped it
no i don't think at that period of
history
maybe within internet
so if you have a time machine to know
exactly how everything happens maybe you
could intervene and have some kind of
impact on it or delay it significantly i
don't think so i think there's too many
things happening at one time and you
know if that's the case is the collapse
of america inevitable and no no action
that we could do is going to change that
but it always has to start somewhere and
then snowball so if you could go back in
time and stop the snowball stop the
crossing of the rubicon yeah well it was
really stopping the expansion of the
roman state because it was got so big
that the technology couldn't support the
infrastructure and they had to split in
half and then at that point it was just
like just down well i thought the 2020
election was that kind of that
inflection point where you saw this the
entire country burn
and how somebody can vote for the party
that created that that uh chaos
was stunning to me so have we kind of
have we crossed that that point where we
can't reverse i i can't think otherwise
but that we can change it and that we
have the tools to do it and that we have
the ability to do it because otherwise
you know we have no hope no i i don't
think there's no hope i think the system
is crumbling before us but it doesn't
mean that we're going to suffer it just
means that
the world around us will change
substantially and we're going to have to
rebuild
from the uh from the ashes i'm not i
don't see it as a bad thing but people
not paying attention will suffer the
people who are ignorant and don't know
what's going on will suffer everybody
watching this show is going to be all
right i guess because they because they
bought all of their food at
safeandreadymeals.com
i think that they do want to put people
in pods and link them into the metaverse
and somehow extract heat from their body
for electricity and like just sedate a
large population that's the most i get i
get it but that doesn't actually work
the extracting heat from your body for
energy electric juice i don't know i
mean they're going to try and find a way
to harvest what is sort of electric
juice electric
isoelectric is when you harness
vibration to create an electrical
current okay so the body's own like your
your bones are made of
hydroxyapatite which is a crystal a
vibrating crystal for instance and if
you could somehow harness the vibration
to get electricity out of it and like if
you're in a fluid that's really
sensitive to vibration and you create
like a static charge just by being
inside of it
um i would imagine rather than kill
everybody off they're going to try and
extract value from the human body
environmentalists are gonna find some
way for that not to be renewable and uh
and argue against it and protest against
it we have we've been having renewable
things for in renewable technology in
nuclear for
30 40 years and
they've been fighting it for uh for that
long as well because
constantly feeding people is a big
weight on the system and that's what the
world economic forum is interested in
not doing they want to do that less
that's why they're like we want to slow
the growth of population and it's a lot
of it's because they don't think that
they can feed it properly do you think
what's happening right now in regards to
the the you know the hitting of the
supply chain and what have you do you
think it's part of a design do you think
that this is actually something that the
world economic forum and those kinds of
globalist
overlords are the ones that are are
causing a lot of this supply chain issue
yeah only in that when i think about the
electricity system like why are we still
on a centralized electricity grid when
there are options for localized fusion
reactors or or fission reactors or local
power systems like they have in africa
in a lot of places where everybody's got
solar on the roof but they've kept us
connected to the grid because that's the
power structure they the city controls
if i have electricity or not so maybe
that they're doing that with food too i
don't that's the only reason why i think
that maybe the food's also involved in
that
food and electricity man if you can
control those you control a nation
so is is the reality that there is no
great crisis but they're manufacturing
it all so they can
centralize and control the human
population yeah
scarcity the way they reacted to covet
was insane they gave us the two weeks to
slow the spread but then when we
realized people's eyes weren't bleeding
like we thought we where was the spread
was done like we okay let's open it back
up now but instead they went the other
direction we fought a civil war with
smallpox that had a death rate of 40
percent and we fought through it we
didn't like stop everything we didn't
like say okay you know we got to we have
to slow bend the curve on this
things kept going people kept doing what
they were doing
but in this sense i mean it was like we
allowed communism to seep right into how
many people would we have allowed to
enter into the the force and die to
fight communism from coming into the
united states how many americans would
we said okay that's worth it to stop
chinese communism from coming into the
united states a hundred thousand two
hundred thousand five million
we allowed it to come in through this
pandemic it just came right in and we
all just put a mask on our face and
stayed in home and it was the it was the
most brilliant execution if you're a
theorist if you're a conspiracy theorist
it was the most brilliant execution to
bring communism and to do a test run on
it then the pandemic was clash robert a
book called coveted 19 the great reset
like he conflated the two things what do
those have anything to do with each
other unless he wants to make them well
he connects he talks about it he says
that this is our opportunity to enact
the great did you see that they ran that
that simulation in 2019 about what to do
if there's a global pandemic do you get
even 301 event through like they were
ready for it like really really ready
for it right before it happened
constantly ready for crises because i
think they understand that's when they
can make cultural moves that's when they
can make these huge sweeping cultural
changes is they're waiting for a crisis
if they can't make if the crisis doesn't
come they manufacture it and um and they
take advantage of those moments it's you
see it throughout history every time
these crisis come along they try to make
these moves and they try to make these
cultural changes and i think that the
the kovid was the perfect example and i
think it's multi-layered i think it's
not just covet i think the plan eve is
is even bigger uh than that because when
covert first hit i was just screaming on
my youtube channel hey the economy is
going to get hit even way worse than
this and i think they calculated this
because they deliberately shut down
small mom-and-pop businesses they
allowed walmart to be open grandma down
the street had cops banged down a bus
down her door shut down her business
because she dared to even be open when
she was running an online business
having that kind of activity absolutely
destroyed the middle class the working
class and i think this was deliberate i
think a lot of the scarcity is
artificial and i think when you have
scarcity you're able to have control
over populations and i think right now
when it comes to the food sector the
energy sector we're seeing deliberate
compromises of those systems in order to
bring in more control for the ruling
party that's just my own personal
opinion and perspective from how i've
been seeing it and where things are
going ever since i learned about i was i
worked at ground zero over nine on 9 11
i actually worked in the american
express building across the street from
the pile from like october to
december and i would sit in this blown
out building
explode the walls were blown out the
windows were blown out i was like i
guess when a building falls all the
surrounding buildings windows get blown
out then later i start to find out
oh maybe maybe there's more concussive
forces at play you start to look the way
they butchered national institute of
standards and technology butchered the
the investigation into that thing and
just shipped off the the steel to china
they didn't invest and then there's all
these like scientists and engineers come
and say well there was trace amounts of
nano thermite found in the dust you look
at the buildings fall they're falling in
near freefall which indicates a
demolition but this silence the radio
silence on this makes me think that
people are complicit i don't know what
else to think i don't know who but but
it doesn't that wouldn't just happen on
accident you've got we're detectives man
we've got the cia
what look into this
why did those things seem to fall in
your free fall speed
it is it is a i've seen so many i
haven't gotten dug deep down into that
world feel like it's
simple as they explained when the fires
weakened the steel
the weight of the upper floors caused it
to pancake creating an exponential
increase in force when the floor hits
another floor
so you would expect to see the pancaking
but that doesn't happen the whole thing
just falls well you
you wouldn't from all the debris and
i'll so you you can actually you can
there's blasts coming out of the windows
and it's funny because people are like
ah those are explosions and like or it's
the pressure the firemen are like
there's a bombs going off on the
building pop pop pop pop pop pop all the
way up and you're like what are they
talking about i got to slap you this is
what i don't like about conspiracy
theories when news reports came out on
the day and it was a lot of conjecture
and confusion and knowing what was going
on
the conspiracy theorists tend to take
that and go wow that proved something
else happened and i'm like or it proves
that you had no idea what the hell was
unfortunately i cannot prove what
happened well that's not my goal there's
a great group called the architects and
engineers for 911 truth and they've
garnered
thousands of professionals in the field
and they break it down more
scientifically and they explain things
uh through logic science and data
while of course nist and all these other
government officials have been hiding a
lot of the data and not highlighting it
to them i just i just want to make one
point on this because you know we're not
i don't think we're going to be able to
tackle this maybe maybe we'll talk about
it in the after show actually we'll go
in real great detail
i have a conspiracy theory you guys want
to hear it oh yeah during the
construction of the world trade towers
we're we're a country that operates on
uh the lowest bidder so there's a famous
quote i can't remember which astronaut
said this they said what was going
through your mind before that rocket
went off into space and he said that it
was built by the lowest bidder
so i imagine this you know there's a
point i make to a lot of conspiracy
theories because people will say stuff
they think like 911 was an inside job or
something and i say okay i hear you
why choose that conspiracy theory over
the other conspiracy theory that in the
70s when they were building this a
construction company the port authority
whatever they said we can build this for
x million dollars and they were like wow
that's cheaper than the other guy the
project is yours then the vp you know
goes to the cfo and he's like
are you nuts
we can't build this structure this big
for that price don't worry about it
we'll we'll skimp on this the stresses
in the center a plane's never going to
hit this building and so they rip off 30
million from the budget so they can get
the job done and then when it gets hit
it falls granted i i know there's a lot
of interesting things we'll talk about
but i'll put it this way
i think uh
people will choose their their end
result instead of starting from the
questions and then trying to understand
what happened and that's the issue i
take with it i got no issue of i'll tell
you this first and foremost 9 11 it was
a conspiracy either you believe it was a
conspiracy between you know these these
saudi nationals these egyptians and
these men to commit this act or you
think it was government actors or at the
very least they knew it was coming and
didn't care either way a conspiracy
occurred that day from that point we
should start asking questions about what
happened why did it happen how did it
happen
unfortunately we have two camps that
have
i'm not saying only two camps we have
two dominant camps one saying we know
what happened they're saying we know
what happened and i'm kind of like the
reality is the government's not gonna
tell you what's gonna happen there's no
way the government would ever tell you
the truth about 911 no sane rational
person would believe it because
simply put they can't reveal how we got
attacked if we did assume like we got to
take the 911.
they're not going to come be like oh
here's exactly how they did it let me
explain for you why so it could be
replicated no they're probably freaking
out but there's a lot of questions but
they don't though they said exactly guys
with box kiters came in did this what
i'm saying is of course that's not true
because there's no way they could reveal
the classified information as to what
really happened so no same person would
believe that story that it that it's an
outright depiction of truth now of
course the media will tell you that only
a crazy person would challenge that but
come on be real you think the government
would come out and be like here's the
classified secrets as to how 3 000
people were killed that day no they
wouldn't they'll tell you a story some
of it may be true but no responsible
member of our government would come out
and tell you exactly how we got attacked
if rand paul would i know you would rand
tell me the truth well let's do this
let's do this let's talk about that
stuff in the members show and go to
super chat and just a quick fact check i
said event 301 it's actually event 2017
i was wrong
event 201 is where they were that's how
you do it mainstream media you you admit
you were wrong it's easy you could do it
eventual ones where they ran a
simulation on a global pandemic in 2019.
yeah very very interesting
so luke because you made one mistake
you're here by fake news just one that's
all that matters
i admit to it i made my mistake the
media can lie cheat and steal all day
and they're called real real news but
you know event to a one's wild i i
didn't know about it until after covid
was rolling wait until you learned about
their cyber warfare program let's talk
about events let's go ahead and all that
stuff from the members only show how
about that we got to go to super chats
otherwise cyber polygon
all right what do we got here
keystone comet says had to go to the
channel page to find the stream no
notifications for at least two days
didn't even see it on my subscription
page today
and uh we can actually see that in the
analytics so the analytics have been
like it's it's obvious they're screwing
with us dude we're two months out of the
election if you want to support the show
knowing this
[ __ ] whoa what just happened did you
turn the power off
no i think the ufo is down oh my gosh
crash landed smash the like button right
now
share the show on all platforms if you
can because they're they're going to
start
you know shadow banning us i'm pretty
sure my instagram is shadow band yeah
tis the season yeah
one too many spicy memes yup yeah
i posted like michael malus was like i'm
i'm pro women's choice and pro science
that's why i'm pro national divorce and
then i posted it and it's like getting
no likes like
my posts welcome to the club i've been
at like 107 k followers for like months
i grew grow grew and then out of nowhere
it just stagnate it's been like that for
like around a year
it's crazy meta is the most highly
policed of all those social networks
heron gaming news says ian is a national
treasure oh smack a national treasure
man
tom wolf says the inflation reduction
act is just a bunch of coupons for green
new deal products true and irs budget
yeah yeah
sideways says i was so happy in 2018
when i had a 1b1b
one bedroom one bath and attached a
garage at 1100 bucks a month went up by
400 cents and i've been back in mom's
for a year plus now i'm so jealous that
you paid that little in rent that's
crazy i'm very sorry you had to move
home that sucks
man
crazy days man
jeremy wein says somebody should send a
fiddle signed nero
yeah
they had a concert yeah you know what
the weird thing is that um you know
people are telling us they're not
getting notifications for the show it
comes and goes in waves
and uh it's weird
you know it i can't imagine it's an
accident at the same time though our
clips segments on the shows are doing
really really well
so i wonder i wonder if they don't the
clips don't have the full shows so i
wonder if they're like
trying to mask that our
our analytics are still up but the live
show is down and the clips are up you
know if you want to get it make sure you
click the bell button in addition to the
subscribe button maybe you can unclick
it and click it again to refresh it in
the algorithm i don't know leaving a
comment on the video i think also
probably tells the algorithm that you
want to see it more we're working on it
we're working on a mobile app but um
maybe we should come up with a browser
extension called notifications
yeah you know we should do this we
should totally we should totally yeah
where you actually see the content that
you subscribe to exactly yeah and then
like you'll have a browser extension and
then whenever
one of your show like you'll you'll put
in there like here are the shows that i
like and then it'll pop up and show you
the shows yeah i would love a tv guide
type like yeah we're working on that
with the with the charity thing although
it's not technically a charity right now
it's just a bunch of developers working
on it but we're putting like a
you know kind of like a google a
calendar type thing but for all the all
your subscribed content where you can
see what's coming trite 54 says my tim
cast the way i like it hot spicy wings
the side of pierogies and psychedelic
mushrooms topped off with some sour
patch kids there you go and not an epic
baked potato in sight that sounds gross
honestly
clever name says luke your timing is
impeccable
you are back just in time for me to send
those effing quarterly taxes out cries
and pounds on the table ah yes
quarterly tax day is coming up in a
couple days so anybody who runs a
business knows how funds that can be so
much fun
yeah you know we have like vendors who
are hitting us up you know telling us
like hey would you like to extend this
extend that and i'm just like it's tax
month we have no budget the government
gets our money don't you know how this
works you could totally see too in
subscriptions like around the tax time
you see a literal dip around around
those uh those moments that we've seen
in our you know well this is quarterly
so it's like the people who run
businesses the average person is working
like a standard what it's like you're
not seeing it yeah they don't they see
they see tax day in april but for people
who run businesses every quarter you got
a tax day
slain hope says i've been i've lived in
la for 43 years and i've it's never been
this bad they tax the heck out of weed
sales and you don't see any of that
reflected in city spending the more they
tax the less they accomplish then why
still live there and the gas right now
over there is almost 560. when i was
driving i was so jealous when i was
driving in here i saw 3 30 or something
on the way in here
california still over there what are you
doing
my family's there my family's there so
it's kind of a kind of a hard thing to
leave we looked into leaving but we
didn't like extended family yeah
grandparents the weather's nice i will
say that you're in la right yes yeah the
weather's really nice down there antonio
says shout out to some anti-woke bands
that don't get brought up here check out
stained aaron lewis is very pro freedom
and anti-well
eric jillian's metal band backwards song
a great equalizer very cool check it out
yeah eric does have a band cool
right on
j j marie says patrick i absolutely love
red pill i am an ex-gang member vato
from the inner city doing my part
creating non-political content and also
do a philosophical podcast i think the
fans will like j marie thesis podcast
cool rad glad to hear it very cool
tyler
bozonovsky says perhaps luke should be
cast as a little merman oh that's a good
idea
i'm okay you're good luke come on you're
luke's our diversity cast member yeah
he's diversity higher it's true because
he's here see i i may be i may be mixed
i don't like the humor here
see luke is 100
uh person of color
literal
this is like from last year right did
they change that and they said now
polish people are people
people people so that's my solution a
little same colors me luke
very very simple it's got blonde hair
blue eyes yeah it's great represent i
love it
we're a minority that's right we are
that's right they actually been they
said that last night on the emmys they
actually said it last night in the emmys
that we are now the majority and you are
the minority
i should say the standard person of
color
randy
choshan mayor says raelians might go on
strike friday biden big fan of the
raelians might deny our right to strike
no contract in three years wage increase
is not close to inflation looking for
attendance policy we work 24 7 schedule
wow
it's coming down when the rails shut
down you ain't gonna have any food
people don't get it
they don't understand man dark days
indeed
louis zelaya says tim did you see that
michael knowles reviewed will of the
people on his show tonight the song left
him speechless oh which is the title of
his book speechless controlling words
um a couple people were saying that did
he he he he reviewed the song i guess he
didn't hear that i usually listen to him
and i didn't hear that one yeah
or maybe he mentioned it and people are
just you know tricking me into reading a
promo for his book yeah but you can do
two things you can add will of the
people
and only ever wanted on spotify to your
playlists and just spam play em and just
blast that music because it's really
really good for us it helps it helps us
and uh we and i mean do it if you like
the music obviously but edit your
playlists you know blast it get
everybody see it the cool thing is with
apple music we're seeing who's shazaming
the song so like someone will be at a
bar and the song will play and then
they'll like what is this song and then
they they add us or whatever it's really
cool cool shout out to michael knowles
you can also buy his book speechless you
can
eric hilarity says 1966 yuri besmanov a
kgb defector warned americans about how
they would slowly take down american
democracy it's on youtube but you should
watch it it's scary how accurate it is
that's right interviewed by g edward
griffin
oh gee edward griffin let's go creature
from jekyll island great book definitely
recommend it and we should try to get
him on the podcast i'd love to i
actually talked to him before and he was
interested it's just a matter of getting
him out here how old is he now he's
gotta be in his 70s or 80s or something
yeah like he's talking about he's up
there but he's he's smart he's he's
still there
not that guy says i'll put my house up
for sale tomorrow where do we go want to
start a business that requires a
storefront 100 serious my property tax
500 bucks a month i don't know
i don't know where to go we're in uh the
west virginia tri-state area so our we
have two big cities we have frederick
maryland and we have charlestown i'm
staying way away from communist maryland
and uh you know i really want to set up
um
it'd be fun to do a pizza place with
like arcade games
skee-ball yeah that's a bonding
experience yeah we played skee-ball ian
one he got 40 000 points we had this
arcade game i accused him of
photoshopping me and cara each had like
a like a rifle and we were shooting it
like it was like a space invaders alien
turret blaster yeah man it was like a
bonding experience for us you know
taking out the aliens together what are
you doing there ian you see me you know
what i'm doing
[Laughter]
one direction
i love those guys they do great work we
went to funky's arcade bar in uh i think
it was in danville virginia i don't
think it was yeah
yeah yeah it was and i walked inside of
this place and i saw
the tables they had beer on tap but it
was like you charge your card with cash
and then you just like pull it and it
calculates so like a full beer was like
two bucks they had skee ball they had
racing games and i was like this is
amazing we need this yeah it was great
you guys have the axe throwing out here
is that a big thing
yeah i mean it's commercial sport and
stuff it's big it's big out where we're
at the yuppie hipsters love it i think
they're trying to get their rule roots
going but i think we need a
you know like an arcade bar kind of
thing games
you know basketball one of those like
basketball games skee-ball you know what
we want to do and we need help if you if
you can help us please please we want to
make ski bowling this is our big idea i
have no idea
skee-balling huh ski bowl
here's what it is it's a bowling lane
but at the end is a launch ramp
into ski ball like targets
and so it's just a massive ski ball with
a bowling ball and you throw the bowling
ball and then it launches up and you're
trying to get the 10 000 and the edge or
the side or whatever ski bowling that's
awesome that's exactly what it is sounds
like fun it would be like super fun and
so the idea i was thinking is like
you don't actually have to use bowling
balls because bowling balls can be heavy
because you want to knock the pins down
this can be a lighter plastic ball
just very a light ball that just you
want to launch and get in the hole
and imagine a bowling lane with a launch
ramp that'd be so fun you could actually
have a bowling lane with the the lawn
[ __ ] that comes down so you have your
ski bowl and then you can pull the ramp
up and actually just put pins down and
actually bowl regular too oh yeah it's a
good idea
yeah you could you could actually
you could have the the the skee-ball
target thing be lifted up and clear out
of the way
yeah that'd be cool
i always wondered how new games were
made it seems like seems like we should
be like done with new games by now like
the human experience should be done and
then there's a new game always coming
especially drinking games drinking games
there's always a new dress i spent some
time with my my nephews recently and
there's all these new drinking games i
had never seen before yeah there's one
it's um it's a drinking game it's really
fun you watch tim cast irl and whenever
tim says civil war you take a drink and
then you die
and then you yeah you get alcohol
poisoning
i got the uh geode griffin actually is
90. 90 years ago yeah i knew he was up
there i knew he was that keeper all
right mavis says michael knowles finally
reviewed tim song will of people during
the during the whole video he was
speechless okay
sat there and stunned silence
you can uh purchase will of the people
and only ever want it on itunes or add
them on your spotify playlists
and um
listen to the songs enjoy them you can
purchase we've got uh i think
what we have coming out in a couple
weeks is probably going to be a lighter
piano version of the song we'll see we
will see you
brienne uh brienne wow why did i say
that brian timmer says
luke how's your german shepherd doing
she's awesome she's in the back of all
my videos right now on my youtube
channel she's always just hanging out we
usually go for like a little walk right
in the morning i shoot my videos she
knows right away as soon as i start
screaming she goes right in the back of
the couch relaxes lays down no she's not
she's like hanging out chilling not even
caring about anything she knows i'm at
work as soon as we're done with work we
go play outside uh she gives me a lot of
exercise a lot of happiness and uh if
you have a dog uh you know they're
they're awesome and incredible and uh i
have a lot of fun and and she she's
helping me get back in shape
a german shepherd okay yeah super smart
very very intelligent dogs that you have
to work with train every single day and
that's what we do and it's been a lot of
work but really fun right on
jake malone says i made the bad thing
browser extension and it's hilarious
check your info email for screenshots
and install info that's awesome so the
idea was that it replaces all of the
right wing words with bad thing
because it doesn't matter what they're
saying it's meaningless so it's going to
be like the right demanded bad thing
and they are bad people
who want bad thing
taking back toxic says he clearly
removed the tags that say not to remove
them under penalty of law
oh mike lindell yeah mike lindell he
pulled the tags off the goddess that
makes sense he's coming for him
he had some top secret tags that they
had to go cover
bobcat says tim look it up the bolshevik
revolution had some of the bloodiest
fighting of the first world war us
troops even got dragged into that mess
leading to the worst retreat in u.s
history until biden
that was a good one
ashborough says any update on discover
card regarding boomstick sale tracking i
applied for a discovered card today oh
yep i got approved
so i have a discovered card coming and
uh
on if if if the news comes out the
discover card's gonna start playing that
same business
or maybe they already do i don't know
i will i will cancel the card yeah i
asked people on my twitter if anyone
could investigate this for us i still
haven't had time to look at all that but
i'm gonna be good
yo they have five percent cash back
that's crazy
five percent discover card sounds pretty
good
five percent cash back no tracking your
gun purchases just a great selling point
yeah there you go that is your motto you
know we should make a fake commercial
for it
i heard you guys talking about it last
night that visa mastercard are
that i was like that's i'm so aghast and
stunned what do they plan on doing with
that information sharing it with
governments yep or putting it in
databases that could be probably hacked
by other but the government you have to
in most places when you purchase a gun
you have to get it right you have to go
through a
screening process i mean i've done that
with all my guns every time i buy a gun
i have to
but it's illegal for the federal
government to create a a firearms
registry so now they're doing it through
the corporations
and they're all they have the list
they'll help the registry that way got
you which is illegal and
unconstitutional
all right what do we got pinochet's
helicopter tours it's an interesting
name lindsey graham and his ladybugs
should go away what is that a reference
to
i have no idea i don't know i'm sure i
haven't heard waffle sensei says would
you kindly spin the ufo we can't ian bro
no i can try though no it's it's not
plugged in is it oh it is it is it's on
now yeah the lights are on like the
little lights underneath it yeah
see if you can do it oh no pressure
trying to one-shot it i can do this
that's the one
can you set it when it's flashing yeah
you can set it here we go come on
we got this
you just put it right there lower your
hands and then find the center oh yeah
all right makes it sound
where's your
trash dude where's your chi where's your
wow impressive
did you not have the camera on it when i
just did that perfectly in one go tim's
smooth one move look at that wobble
you're gonna mess it up that's because
of gravity no or is it magnetism it's
you gotta actually bro too much gravity
you gotta meditate more bro you're right
i should be more still it's the momentum
when you push one side that one side
stays down the whole time bouncing up
and down so it creates the wobble
because the universe is curved yeah no
it's because you you applied downward
force to the appearance
yeah
physics
well we spun the ufo waffles so uh
accomplished
brad turley says tim everywhere i go is
a riot people crying young turks
everywhere you go you is silent why so
quiet
that's a reference to uh
not the actual lyrics but tom mcdonald's
song riot it's actually a really good
song i like it riot have you guys been
listening to it it was catchy yeah it is
it's really good but the course is
catchy yup
i dig it people love that guy yeah i
mean he's good it's awesome stuff and
he's
i just love the smack talking the
establishment that's that's what it's
all about but this song right it's not
overly political but it is
anti-establishment so good stuff man
time you rock
you guys should check out tom mcdonald's
right buy his song on itunes help him
hit number one if he does hit number one
on the hot 100 which is a stretch we
will all wear suits that's right
but we'll see maybe maybe he'll hit
number one it's in some fashion and then
we'll just wear suits because it'll be
funny people are requesting i wear a
corduroy suit yes yeah that'd be perfect
luke's going to wear a pimp suit damn
right
right
oh you can't appropriate my culture
what color is your corduroy tan brownish
tan really hot yeah interesting purple
or green i don't know i'm looking for
something like that oh my gosh no
username to display says they there are
indeed aliens partly responsible for all
the evil and insanity they are called
demons
yo dmt is some of the craziest stuff
yeah i would love because the stories i
hear about that people talk about demons
and i wonder if that's they see demons
just because
their world view is molded around the
ideas you know what i mean yeah like if
someone didn't know anything about
demons what would they call it
and would it exist
like would they perceive it
you know what i mean what is it is it a
liquid or is it it's in your brain right
now and every time you dream your brain
lets it out a little bit it's like
you're born with it and your brain is
flooded with it when you're born with it
when you die your brain is flooded with
it as well and people could artificially
take it to pretty much uh see what
happens when they die interesting
yeah the choroidal there's part of the
brain
yeah people say how they literally see
their soul leaving their bodies and they
talk to entities and little elves and
some demons and some other creatures
that are more loving and caring and give
them answers to a lot of their life
problems and i've heard sounds like a
litmus test of where you are mentally at
that time some people have said that
demons offer them a deal
they'll give you knowledge and
information
and then they're like no no i don't want
it i don't want it that sounds like a
psychotic trip kind of that there that
you're going through people have shared
experiences what's crazy about yeah like
two people will like
sit near each other but in different
rooms and take it and then they'll
experience like
the same thing the same the same place
like you'll see the same people and
everything
that's crazy yeah it makes you
understand that there's a bigger
spiritual and action and aspect to our
existence that we still don't even know
about i was talking to somebody who told
me like don't take the deal it's a deal
it's with a demon you can't take it you
got to resist and i was like why like
they'll tell you
that they know the truth
and they know what's really going on
they want to help you but but it's not
really help it's a trick they're demons
trying to manipulate you and then i was
just like well what's bad about the deal
like why shouldn't you take the deal
what bad is gonna happen you can't do it
because it's bad and i was like you know
it's kind of weird because that kind of
sounds like what the media says about
alex jones alex jones says i'm just
trying to let you know i'm trying to
help you and they say no he's evil he's
grifting he's trying to manipulate you
and he's saying no i'm just giving you
the information you need i'm trying to
help
so it's like there's also a lot of
people who take it who are like you've
got to take it you got to take it and
again it's a personal journey from my
point of view i think the best advice is
telling people hey do your own research
listen to your gut make your own
decisions for yourself don't take advice
from podcasters yeah yeah i'll give you
some advice though when the demon comes
to you
you don't have to respond keep that in
mind you'll start to feel afraid but
override that and listen to it and
you'll realize it takes on a
conversational tone and it's part of you
yeah invoke the demon take his powers
i did that burning his energy yes you
can do that you did that at burning man
yeah you stole the demon's powers
thinking instead of speaking i remember
thinking speak to me demons speak to me
and it started this noise
just cr erupted from the audio like
there's thousands of musics going on all
at once across the play reverberating
creating this mega music and it came out
of the music this like vibration this
really and it was like moving up and
down i couldn't control it and then it
took on the sound of this voice
and i just stayed calm and then it got
conversational and i realized this is
just me talking to myself this is one
thing people don't often uh realize
because you know we only do the show at
night but periodically throughout the
day several times a week ian will you
know all of a sudden his eyes will turn
black and i'll start floating that's
true it's very weird things will start
flying around the room and then we got
to like bop him on the head with a
little stick and then he comes back down
and then we're like stop it stop it
cashew ice cream that's the real problem
he's like and then you're like how does
this cashew ice cream start he was like
oh and then he comes back down monk
fruit
there's another super chat that i think
is i think it's kind of pretty good i
don't know if i could read it one by
howard for a hundred bucks and he's
asking if cat catherine austin fits uh
use cash now have her on she has been
making a lot of pretty interesting
videos and what about um
specifically about the smart grids the
smart cities and how a lot of the new
technology is being integrated to
control humanity she was a part of the
bush administration
she was in in
you know in the white house working with
them and then she came out and revealed
a lot of the bigger plans when it comes
to the centralization of power and
authority she's a great thinker she
thinks outside the box i don't always
agree with her but i think she would be
definitely awesome to have as someone to
come on to warn and talk about what
she's been researching and studying we
have a big show tomorrow so we don't we
don't reveal who our guests are but
tomorrow is going to be crazy big shirt
yeah big one and then friday as well is
going to be crazy we're poking the bear
with these next couple shows so this is
going to be a lot of fun all right
homeslice 97 says it's a type 1 diabetic
i've had to swallow the very hard pill
that no matter how much i prep i cannot
survive a total collapse it keeps me up
at night you can you just need a pig
farm oh yeah um you need what are they
what do you do isolate insulin from the
pig oh yeah that's right that's how they
do that
i would learn about that yeah i'll tell
you this
buddy i'm not a doctor so i would
encourage you to take the proper
educational courses to learn how to
perform the veterinary skills on a pig
in such a way that you can extract the
insulin from his body and i think the
challenge is that like it would kill the
pig
maybe not maybe maybe you can take
enough of its insulin or whatever but no
you can probably figure out how to
synthesize or not maybe not synthesize
but
um harvest yeah insulin from like pigs
that's what they did right that's that's
the first i'm pretty sure it's the first
thing they did i believe so they're like
kids were dying and they didn't know why
and then somebody was like i'm gonna
take this thing from pig give them the
kids got better and they're like hey
this thing's helping and then we figured
out oh it's insulin i think a lot of
people are taking up those kinds of
things now from homesteading to
growing their own food because of
everything that's happening i think it's
a silver lining and a lot of what we've
been seeing yeah and homeschooling as
well yes all right ron gerion says
caesar crossing the rubicon wasn't the
start of the fall of rome if anything
the creation of the empire led to much
needed reformations and purging of
corruption that delayed the fall by two
centuries yeah but at what cost you know
destroying an evil system to create
something evil isn't necessary was it
evil though was the empire either empire
well it was an empire it was one guy
deciding and then all the emperors start
getting killed off by other people that
want to become emperor i mean that's
pretty evil goblin king dude yeah to
become the goblin king you got to kill
the goblin king so everyone's constantly
just
doesn't work out very well
what do we got we got more what is this
about jesus christ lucas ferguson says
interesting thought ian about being
willing to die for someone else despite
what you believe jesus christ died to
absolve everyone from the beginning of
history to the end of history's sins
i hope he did and what i mean is i hope
he actually
absolved people
but i don't know if someone dying does
that
you gotta absolve yourself
you gotta be humble man and speak your
mind publicly
i like let go of my secrets it was it
was something i did on it on the
internet i was like let me just tell my
secrets to keep
blocking my thoughts i keep thinking
about this crap so i started making
internet videos about it and i started
clearing my mind up and i thought
actually maybe i've controlled my
morality makes you harder to be attacked
as well too if you don't have anything
in the closet what can they attack yeah
don't be afraid to speak the truth
here's an important one david door says
my cat watches chicken city every day
when i'm at work
yes
chicken city so um one of the new baby
chickens is brooding what yeah what like
it's it's it's an adult now premature no
no but it is early it is early so you
know uh kim our chicken tender was
saying she's not she was surprised to
see her first year was brooding this
basically means she's trying to have
babies and kim walked over and tried
picking her up and she she pecks at you
because when the chicken's brooding
she's like she wants to plop down and
catch some eggs but it's too late in the
season which is a bummer because you
real the best way to have chickens is to
have the chickens have the chickens
because then they protect them
but by the time
the chickens are feathered it's going to
be winter and it's just they're going to
have a really hard time of the cold so
we can't do it
but uh come springtime hopefully they'll
get broody and then we're going to hatch
a bunch of babies
the roosters will get into cocktown and
i'm ready to eat them but chris doesn't
want to eat them
and get attached to him
well i don't know he wants to let let
him give him a chance to survive in
nature he likes to watch animals
experiment with like watching their
growth process well i don't know he just
doesn't want to kill him and he's like
if they can survive on their own that's
their that's their their their choice
and their chance killing them is killing
them but letting them go hey that's
that's their responsibility
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com become a member one of a
member's only show and i guess we're
gonna be talking about 9 11. it is it is
a couple days after people were asking
for it so we'll go for it we'll go for a
conversation about it
and uh don't forget to show tom mcdonald
some support by buying his song riot
this is the reporting week he released
the song on friday tom's awesome he's
he's anti-establishment he's fully
independent he's very successful and
these are the kind of voices that we
want to succeed in music industry and i
would love to see him just shatter the
billboard charts so that
we can prove that we don't need these
institutions anymore and we're taking
over
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
you can follow me at tim cast you can
check out our songs will of the people
and only ever wanted on spotify check
them out listen to the music buy them on
itunes and uh what did i say tim cast
you can follow me if you'd like uh
patrick you want to shout anything out i
want to shout out my wife um for it's
our 19th anniversary she's here with me
thank you so much
partner in crime and i want to say the
to everyone's watching support this team
i'm telling you i see all of these
entities that are out there producing
content these guys talk about what's
important what they talk about the
importance of culture they talk about
the importance of taking back this all
through culture and it's something that
i think you guys need to support because
if you don't support this
you lose it it doesn't you don't have
the power that we need to have we need
people like this to thrive so please
support this show absolutely what was
your website again it's
redpilledamerica.com where we publish
every friday we're also on the radio
every weekend on iheartradio
and we're a good old-fashioned
storytelling show we um typically about
35 to 40 minutes each episode and
sometimes we do deep dives and and what
have you i'm gonna go check it out thank
you so much for coming on my website is
lukeuncensored.com i did a video there
about the ai
robotic apocalypse that is coming our
way as an ai developer just came out
today and said that we have three years
left as humanity i talked about that
look uncensored.com hope to see you
there right after this video ian always
a pleasure luke thank you thank you
great to see you man tim lydia thank you
guys so much and i love you guys out
there thank you for being here and
listening and watching and chatting and
getting involved uh i want to point you
towards timcast.com because tonight
cass castle episode 4 has gone live on
the website and if you want to see it uh
the episode's called the big lie if
you've been following it there is
there's a corruption scandal brewing
luke luke was telling me how excited he
was for it yeah it's so fun it's
basically uh the synopsis is in the
first episode
i'll avoid as many boys as possible but
ian runs for union president
and then uh you know they're they're
counting everyone's cheering but uh well
you know hold on there's other employees
at the company who aren't here so they
have to vote uh uh you know
outside but but we'll we'll make sure we
count all those in at three in the
morning the votes come in
and then uh you can imagine what happens
to ian's election so go to teamcast.com
and subscribe log in and on the left
you'll see cass castle you get there
from there you see episode four the big
lie and i will see you guys later i
actually might not be around this week
too much i know we have multiple guests
this weekend so i may not be here i may
be here we'll find out if i don't see it
till next week i love you i'll catch you
later tomorrow is going to be crazy yeah
tomorrow is going to be really important
politically so you guys definitely want
to put us on your calendars i'm not
going to say too much because in the
event sometimes people cancel but we got
some big people are gonna come and we're
gonna have a really interesting
conversation yep i am very excited about
tomorrow it's gonna be awesome but today
was great as well thank you so much for
coming patrick i'm looking forward to
listening to your podcast i'm gonna add
this to my rotation so i'm not just
getting current events also some
historical context will be perfect and i
hope the rest of you guys will join me
with that as well you guys can follow me
on twittermines.com at sarah patrick's
as well as my own site sourpatchlids.me
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you